hello everyone welcome to simply lans
youtube channel 4 aow the new york then
I put my to you ticket it to the
future lady russell popping up in a
freelance man who have you can that is
always just for you to argue we de tab
vending technologies the karin ideal as
free
the do you have plant beds in the right on
must d'ruit technology
paste him had a semois far less
because lego league if the cloud
computing de tardis
because on the mos profilo to the om the man
the tubers came musical for
first it can be the cloud computing' cloud
computing the technology that jesus in the
disruption of managing the dan om
remote will was a hare in the dk wai
less neck
the stench of 16 allows users to promote
some of the most popular cloud service
provider star had such an idea is blue
microsoft azure google cloud platform
and much more
industry guide you will only ball cloud
computing' and longueur coming samples
for both learning experience
summer day for a day or by experts
hi there comes a from simply lang en en
what is a modular plan architect
and trainer and lammie welcome you to so
learn how to do that even what is cloud
computing
s who gets tall so cloud computing and
we will also be learning about how tanks
were for cloud computing' and benefits
or cloud computing'
the van types of cloud computing' and
fennel and the some of the famous company
is the weird using cloud computing' and the
gearing benefit can long black like
computing' and sister that girlfriend and that
ethical service or application
lechat basic web server it is not come
easy well here is a parent or business
and i know you have guessed it odori
labs ronnie and successful business by
looking at the heart and fresh group of
venus death and lots and lots of people
were you and now the autumns my love you
smile again but really smart work and so
fresh ko mark and don one fine day colmar
can set up you would like to do business
online in your marriage the signs
business online
before he humbles a website like
the for cutting and market pot everything
barely together and [ __ ] about this
requirement that his bars should not be live
servers and database and software to get
his business online which means love in
west moment and mark last is bad
boys will lead to in west arm en qua en
technical experts the manage the hardware
and software that doubles the jars of singles
also the torture infrastructure and
activation everything is mailbox monastery
dropping is plan for sale online but
before she may the decision to chose to
check if there in the outnet tips where
so you do have panel of money and do
not to spend torment technical
expertise now that's why mark open
discussion what is bass and has plays his
boss about cloud computing and here
splinter is bursting champagne dongle nothing
plan to you and some time now about what
is great computing
what is cloud computing' cloud computing'
is the usaf and network or remote service
hosted on the internet to store my
nature pals did a rather than heaven
always locally and using local server
that cloud computing' is something malfunctioning ar
detail in the internet from anywhere and
access an out detail from anywhere to
out the internet and the company is there
leaving services or cabbage the cloud
providers cloud computing' is also be
able to deploy and manage your
applications services and network to all
too close and manage them through the
web management or configuration portal in
adwords cloud computing' service
providers that was the evolution
to manage your applications and services
to a global network of internet i
sample of such providers on amazon web
services and microsoft azure
after we never word cloud computing'
is let's talk about the benefits of
cloud computing' that can't count the
cloud benefit's is what is driving closed
caption like and went in the reason they
want and ideas or at servicenow blue
it's available for me almost instantly
history and is ready for action almost
the same time now this reduces the live
did and the product and service you
market almost in cynthia's click add
to the legacy and bram en and the because
of this the company has started to
generate revenue to booster next day i
snap the cd planning and by the whites is
hardware has always been a challenge in
legacy and shapes and if you look so when
doing this to my title of the hardware
that's on the site for the rest of you
life with cloud who don't buy in
hardware bah who use the hardware and
pay for the time who is it is that
harvard is not fit requirement releases
and start using a bad configuration and p
oil for the time you start a new and
barack a situation in legacy in lammens
forecasting is the man and full-time job
bar the cloud weekend with the marching en
automation tool to work for you and to
properly scale up and down the roses
based on downstairs of that are not only
that the roses services date a can be
accessed from anywhere s long knife again
are connected to the internet and i you
we and they had tools and techniques now
available which will let you to walk of
life and will think when ever it
internet is or apple mac insure de
details thorin double storage and in his
profession is the talk of the business
and francis questing that million dollars
with clawed the dirk can be stored in and
highly durable stories and drip
times when michael regions of yuan and de
the detail that historically encrypts and
secure and affection that beyond what we
can imagine en loco datacenters nou als
blade into the discussion about details
or cloud computing lacdr became my title
ways to categorize cloud computing'
desks it ever-growing well we have
also category out of all the 6th of vote
maud in ok glass in cloud based on the
clients and colleagues in cloud based on
services and I another the plugins
categorizing game based on made it
Implement inside now it's private
is the audience everything the hybrid and me
a gift house in the beast of the
service providers it's infrastructure
something like the ceiling girl so there is
is it software sso so lets look at
them one by one
let's talk about the thief and tips of
cloud based on the deployment models
stuck in public cloud editing history and
actions in and true the internet and the en
internet users what tighter potions can
be viewed and access to some of the
obligations under sources and public
cloud relax oil encounter beets de
hardware or software
everything is managed by the provider
english as your and google for some
examples of public cloud private cloud
india de hen with private cloud de
infrastructure is exclusive to
that poor sitchin's single obligation
knows schuster from the round lo lo loko lé
loko chair pink to a public cloud
provider huisman and services and when
this is that this is the infrastructure
will be maintained and a private network
some examples of how to create a workflow and
solve the aid of this product a very
good example for private cloud he
pantsless redrawn scariest the gods
new level with hybrid cloud who get the
best of both public and private cloud
applications which keeps some of their
applications locally and solid
application will be present in the cloud
wangi sample is nasa this users have
this users private cloud to store sense
to detail and users public cloud to
store and chair detail show notes and
sewer confidential leds now discuss
build cloud-based anchovies mono
the frost and the product category is
infrastructure is a service area we
be because the service network storage
and will ship for them in and ali
business by google increases its actions de
resources who producer and for sam we
will help you cliffs lexus is easy
to in appetite is a very quick sample
know who he thinks will trade him luxury
studio s&f my actions the hardware that
next up of service module is bi platform
a service
well in this model who providers wi-fi and
free
boot ceiling weekend apply a coach and
applications and they will be up and
running who's only not the moon is for sale
and then the infrastructure in here
software as a service the cloud providers
cells containing one project witches and software
or an application
and who derek lead by the software and
subscription bases something of the in
snatches platform body and product true
the software or function not application
and who pay for the hours reviews de
software and hiring that customer maintained
full control of the software and therefore never
maintaining a comment amazon review of
social work star software and services
discharge of explains the difference
between
the formula starting from a promise to
infrastructure adesso view platform is
a service tool software as a service
this self I split that the ressort
manage my eyes off you seen on premises
that will be you're left as you watch and
its little less and infrastructure
services be move for the transverse right
and further reduce and platform is a
service and this one wants an antique that
way when it comes to software sos
micro weed by the software after a
infrastructure camps and touch to know
let's talk about the life cycle of the
cloud computing' solution the very first
and in the life cycle of a solution of
the cloud solution is to get up rapper
understanding of the requirement fck
press warm and some set in a proper and the
mood or came back and it's barry
white oil chose only then you will be
able to properly [ __ ] the white service
offered by the provider getting is an
understanding and lasting would be to
define the hardware opinion choose the
computers that will provider right
support away and resize the computer
capacity in the cloud for an application
program religions already styling of
press warm and help his [ __ ] in the white
hot one size does not fit all day all
the fun services and hardware for the
friend needs and you might have like i
say to you looking for a jacket and lambda i
feel looking for solo lesson computer en
ics dead to rights container rust
anyway a warm heart was your apple [ __ ]
the neighborhood hardware that sweet york warm
starting is the divine the story choose
the great stories is week and a suit
your detail and assets torosaurus weekend
or private in detail louis vuitton de
cloud order from the internet and choose
the great stories that is one separately
for backup gold s3 and that's one
separately for archival dat for this you
so you know a good friend of doing
some really something great service for
the neighborhood and not the of the network
designer at work that securely delawares
detail video and applications define and
identify the network services broccoli
for simple bbc four network red for q3
for dns and dark connection for private
bidipi line from your office studio
ether loop data center therapy that de
security services i'm for authentication
and authorization and kms for a day
encryption at rest so that we are righty or cq
production lot of bizarre pictoright
didn't win the horn and decoration or
deployment and the arm is one and marketing
tools that i can pick from free sample
cloud lunch is for marching parents
killing is for those who elastic and close
formation is defined management process
and tools you can control it completely of
your cloud and then do my review define
the management tools which might as you
ready with resources and of the custom
applications
when bruce platform the device or
the prime and automation and modelling
tools you can take from my cloud watch
for managing a so killing for poor
girl and the cloud formation for the
fold people knowing that will help you
and defining the life cycle of the cloud
computing' solution and symbolize live
tools for testing and process life coach
star and could build and could buy fly
these tools which you can wild test and
the pleat also quickly and finally was
bad luck and then click DNA litec
service for analyzing and realizing the
detail yugi analytics over six weekends
start clothing the detail instantly and
get so if you want to visually view the
hot wings on your android my kind pikte
athena and the test for analytique
or humor and the elastic map widget
videos and the club church
congrats to sammy and bear to
the costs of blog post in which they
flexpin basic frame also on amazon web
services and explore all with a bath and
services and easy to
lambda s3 hi and and cold from mission blue
the dokkumer so and together with popular 6
hello everyone slim introduce myself as
a
mit ceiling throne architect and trainer
and m popular and and peak oil site on the
talkie walkie to this section about what
i do business and talked about some
services and of rings and about how
companies graffiti by my reading their
obligations and infra into english zo
going crazy let's talk about that
number for dead let's talk about how
life force me cold amy cloud provider en
this case a life boards paid in it
preferably something like back and picture
attitude heavy back into those who does
not show longer on while other changes
love you for better care happened since
that time now would be back into and the
quest for and news about is not and
having that would be good life way of
validations life planning and living in
getting so for online on their sources and
century and after you finally got so it's
not all set and then the ladder
optimizations led nice to be done on
that through to make it be and the me
does well then in west my van
that kind and the century and behind we have
optimized for a good return on
investment' the work is to not done there
will often be a free king crisis and the
crisis in the capacity and the in oh I am
news about our website getting
popular am getting more it's called quiet
and the bitter sweet experience which now
and i do and more add sauce by warm in
which means that it's cool to cost me
even more but thanks to the present day
cloud technology museum situation what the
have a 2 my news about it's almost
ready and its way the instantaneously en
whitby swift tools and technologies dat
amazon is confusion oh intro string
my driver instantaneously and
handicap of work load on top of it and
make my store you know sophie secure and
upgrading and durable storage where did
a palace tower in the cloud never gets
lost on it all that features amazon
edgar back she let's talk about what is
it worth the dollar definitions for it
bath and stir put together a simple and
precise definition as much as possible
it's lammie in the cold cloud
stop by and hardware and the website
features in that infrastructure in the
cloud infrastructure with mixcloud cloud
with with interviews and cloud provider
well who get all the services all
technology is all features and both
frits that who gettin all local
datacenter like a security and computer
press the i&a databases and in fact euro
note new nice cool features like
content caching and workflow luck
locations' to the plans where the game
arm all features the best part is the
orient ipad force to aps wego model
the lesson to use the lesson ipad and the moral
use the les taipei polio just want you
factor is in this project and that's not
all the applications that we've
officially in the blue star
whether the life of pi coast part in
and reliable infrastructure and the its way
scalable picos it slow and andaman
infrastructure and something barry flexible
big eyes off the design are the kiss on the
the are options available for me in the
cloud let's talk about how thus have a
appetite was launched in to 2002 after
the amazon
winos that online retail store because it
device became mining and use it
infrastructure and so it has enough room
for customers to buy and use it from
them in a cell infrastructure is a
service that clicks audiosurf and the
appetite launched their first project
force product in 2006 touch light for
you have the idea lunch and in 2012 and
which apply and big size customer and
together inputs and concerns from
customers and have the job i did
rather and making those request help
and there have the currents follow there
something tubing follow travel who in went by
appetite and from 2014 amazon and unstuck
revenue to be four points nothing management en
in 2015 print 2016 edu plus large
projects and services of money my great
customer services into the great wide
web production in the for back this is my
life focus whiskey bananas and looping
migrating sauces and in the same year
that in 2016
ms our life was new
camping en nac with not the least as we
speak
poor relief he is more than 100 products
and services which does for customers
and could benefit from
just let's talk about the
even that's her elbow and amazon
something that we so product protest rhino s3
is a great tool for internet grab
and this is the cheapest stories option in
the object storage category and marley
that this did that white powder nestorius
driver built from the internet s3 is
really cool and who have to the
production like on migration and sharing
are equal and within the window
project and here weekend after oil leaked
detail seamlessly but car in one
real time wants to monitor gita or analyzed
the detail gatsby exactly that the coolpix
like produce their plans for red bull
air helps a cheap dat and then who's got what
I slept easy to unfortunately the computer
outlets and flushing the toilet computer
graphics anytime anytime from the details
of the computer based on a de not of
based on the forecast danny him simple
notification service systems and tools
and dirt and amazon do on details with
modifications to email to sms to a
ring a kenbé center email address msc
views that's how it is copies la maison du
du service novation's if you want to
black tie and then we him sometimes i u
tools like msc management system how to
user cs your prefer expat encryption
and clubpie dk aged less than we have
landa sms follow how ep or before the time
in seckens seccker
it takes to execute a chord and the
winner pink for infrastructure in 60
seconds
and the problems will take to execute
the corrupt the shot program will be
paid in military keys and piglets
program offers probably been in the
section sensor land reclamation secans by
barts lets cheap lat simple and the shed
cost stock houses games games for
service than a battery business which
ladder had dutch chamber anyway
music farming is late cheaper than
their and save who is his service like
growth for free trade dns service in the
cloud and now on you had to maintain and
business account sombreros and my cloud
and poor again and do it in the us too a
get bol in the simply red light invoice
bolts and palais de views mix life
easier on how companies god benefited by
using english as their high tea
delete for the applications or for
the infrastructure well you prefer is the
company and the refocus problem and
dip i english as a solution to the
problem spot after this camp new service
spread across one and two countries and
they're really an alarm digital
marketing for promoting the project and
their existing and back on with the legacy
local and weather poor and green not to
support the changing item and its update
handsome standing who are star oil and flame
now they chose to mobile applications to
english because they belong' getting
what they want and in their local en
poor again and and since then in a shed
where easy profile joop locations became
easy and you and producing a bottle
actor start easy and open the world
online in push buttons killing and not
lessons talk about
backups to die safe and backups the can
basic you reactions of the ailment s no de
hub company has been glowing for a long time with a
buick nose agnes white muscle and rolling
out the fold man and the be able to
oxalis secureback caterpillar from orphan places
and gender reports and intact shows for
report outfit die hipster business the on
the same lines lebioles the acting
builds
likes and had gambetta photo by using
amazon now guys hello that formula something
of a bicycle can be their business
model was barry depend on a and infra
deadpool help to analyze did a really
fast red bridge the running promotions
based on the and lists detail that I
have zoë be able to respond to be
analyzed eating as soon as possible with
classical writer and there and we're on
me and luckily
saab mariana and again different what this is not
it and the content I dip so is in the
cloud and that will also massively solve the problem
to the company does not happen that we
maintaining the legacy in flow and the
meeting barry computer bag city and
maintaining their the db is local ie already
that is no more the cloud by the using
cloud esther aikido provider and the en
well we have twitter and barfly tnv run
less that very much problem and their
business haydar amca wheel and man die
ceiling cloud architect l m when site
and hello to work it through this
learning serious about english lammie
state the station we this scenario
les imagine how live for him a
account spotify photos markings boat
spotify for the fourth time on spotify
its online music service offering and
sacrificing them in stone actions over 16
million license to size spruce fine
users and glass cloud to disturb detail
and shared their customers by trillarden
elias de he jimmy choo's immagine using
spotify before i dubious let's talk
about that batman users will often
careers be caused by the fact not keep
up for the increased the man for storage
avenue d&d beauty you just getting setup
and use scheduling the subscription de
problem spotify was pacing the time
lords de users will present globally and
we action sing it from a glass and the de
hedgren latency less applications with
spotify had the mouth situation
where they need to frequently walking
sometimes released sdw-t day and in the
future and this with changing every day
and the sometimes coming in reed was and what
2000 day and back when they couldn't
keep up with and evil men and needless to
say never be looking for ways to solve
this problem and that's when the garden
to use the interviews and it was a
perfect fit and much for the problem
baby us all for and dynamically
increasing storage and that becomes in die
chain loop as if there were tools and techniques
like storage lifecycle management and
trusted advisor to listen properly
sorry sorry always get the best out of
her so you give us a dress de concerns
about easily be able to say yes i can
skill the earlier blouse and grande mine
very easily hou is oli white as it's
just a few walking clicks and apple's will
the spotify is problem let's talk about
how we can help you with your
organization's problem let's talk about
what is a blouse frost and let's be
into how bow blouse the game so successful
and the for a thai service is that is
plus provides and watch the future of
claws to elias a specific let's
talk about them and finally wind had
built and use case where you will see
how easy it is to create a web
application or rather blush alright
let's talk about what is english english
or amazon web services is secure cloud
service ceiling it's like
vs guide billing moodle what's up nope
friend of capital brush wind had about
how to the service will be able though de
service would be available in a matter
or seconds
becomes in dubious role so do identity
and access management that is
authenticating analyzing and user all
program under flight and almost all
the services are available on the man
and most of them are available in
students cls who speak and john office
towel lesson services and disclose the
growing and who new week after we met
your maintenance in the bios starts like this
successfully chose their customers let's
talk about the list of well-known
companies that guy's guide to add a
comment in eps gift gift views widow
listen provide multi terabyte operating
and guidance for its customers by
integrating the system becomes elias
cloud also had a full sun deploying and
upgrading is to subdivide software with
line to deploy and manage the
infrastructure at b&b is and other
company is a community market place
that allows property or no central axis
to connect each other for the purpose of
and renting unique location space is here
ashore and the dab and micrometer
users' activity or connected to the
website and true iphones and android
applications airbnb as a huge
infrastructure and a blush and therefore
had to use all services in interviews
and getting benefit from the and other
shampoo would be autodesk autodesk a
download software for engineering
designing and editing mindustries using
anyway slide amazon aws or switch db
service and amazon s3 poor such a simple
store it service autodesk and focus on the
planning but the calling is machine
learning to insert of spending the time
and managing infrastructure email of
america online
usa iffy and the using interiors de
have able to close the recent earth
and the commission about friend at home and
content and the cool kids osn nice mission
critical pencil in the cloud and xtandit
global reach and safe millions of
dollars in energy resources bitdefender
is an internet security software phone
and their portfolios actors in cloud
antivirus and antispyware project
bitdefender use it easy to and their
granty running 400 instances that lever
about 5 terrabytes of they do and they
also use elastic load balancer to
love balance the connection coming into
box instances on krasava lea'bilities
us and the provider seamless global
delivery of service because of that they
be because lee group in usa dubious about
the new connected car' application
that collects sensor detail from a bm de
blue seven series cars the game drivers
that's the name I give you updated my permission
know us office imaging production
division benefits from foster deployment
and lower costs and global reach by
using english delaware cloud based
services such as my prince the office
amazing project official user english
good luck amazon s3 and amazon robbed three
amazon cloud print and amazon i'm for the
testing double on mine and production
services comcast is the world's largest
cable company and the leading provider
of internet service in the united states
come catch you also be used in a library
and dry mud of all those had the cloud
providers comcast scores tbs for it
flexibility and scalable possessed
infrastructure dark is a company that
shell ring redefined the way share purse
big ship and of applications this company
focus on making use of containers for
this poppers and and in the blouse de
service colin de amazon easy to
container service is helping them but
she did the essay of european space
agency aldo macho first is work is done
by sites same program detail storage
and computing infrastructure is built on
amazon web services
ese jones english because of its
economical ps go system s wel assets
quick start on time the guardian usb per
user seriously and it users and wide range
or rather angry saint loading amazon
kylie's amazon redshift that power and
analytique dashboard your it editors use
to see how story so trending in the
real time financial times ft is one of
the world's largest
leading business news agnes action and
they used amazon rip shad the found en
everything is a funny thing have an amazon
deadshot professor could lead at
somali stop it was man functioning
never used to running gloves over might
and the feathers elsewhere in the
project just as much faster by using
amazon ritchie ft supporting so a
business functions what does that cost one
that percent was a lower than what was
before chandler i see is breathing les we
speak migrating modern my home and
workloads coloring 3 hundred dashboard
jarppi systems to add us why we're using
its dennis and the foot print from rate
for the for oregon exteriors similarly
howard medical school it stacy hi him
baby with download nasa along and let
more on using the services amazon
provides and getting benefited from met
and the barn yew and customer portfolio
with just the tip of the iceberg and
everything why so many and ap dubious en
violet earlier review the quest and this
is what the blouse with c-people adaptive
blouse blouse of the security and utility
or share and and and privacy and
encryption dating and storage
experts we can rely on you blues
way of doing things by using the hero
bios tools and techniques enthusiast
best practices' is built up an the us of
experience in the child flexibility
a thousand greater flexibility an appetite
that allows to select the eyes lie words
and database easy-to-use
business and deploying week and how-to
locations quickly in earlier usb en
new progression of my clothes and
excisting application in to give us
scalability the application can be
easily is kilda park skilled and
depending on the user requirements for
saving who to jp for the computer
storage and other social issues and that
your pay and not long then can with human
and all the tight plates the franchise and
services the ether loop provides the
selfies is that now talk about full any
of the falling pedigrees you see like en
also computer reach database security
customer engagement ass up and swimming
mission long galloper chair fabric light
up and if i do not cds or is that you
looking for it's probably is blue
cities blouse is created in the s week
na lets look at some of them their very
common use what a computer services how
him amazon in situ amazon elastic
beanstalk amazon light shade and amazon
lambda amazon easy to provide computer
fit that is in the cloud capacity and
secure and it is resizable based on user
requirements to look at this
requirement for the web traffic capes
changing and behind friend in the cloud
easy to know i saved general my de
three instances and using lolo this can
quite the n dry winter coat winter sometimes
tricky beanstalk in health as to scale
and deploy web applications and its met
and number of programming languages
aschwin step is also an easy-to-use
service for the client skilling web
applications and services de blythe en
provides a sharla that just psp node.js
site and ruby ​​docker and ladder family
services such as apache passenger and abs
start simple upload a agree and
elastic beanstalk other medical
levers that the plan my lung capacity
professional and to load balancing de
auto scaling application auxiliary engine and
amazon light cillessen watcher private
server what is easy to launch and easy to
manage amazon lights alice de isis
second get started white blouse for the
walking routes do not and what your private
driver injury affect everything you
need to launch your product good oil
on and word might want like ssd
beasts story churchill machine tools
for the transfer ts management and
install the copy and that to for real
and predictable price earlier islam de
hashtag in cloud computing services to a
whole new level iittala of fuel oil
for the champion time no need for
processing and managing servers and en
jolanda is a champion service that
something like rancor paid more professional
managing service landa execute you could
only one lead and skills aromatic
from fury-class try it like a
sporting goods store and you at oil for the
computer you can you that is no charge when
you or is not swimming lets look at some
storage service is that amazon providers
leak amazon s3 amazon pleasure amazon
ebay and amazon elastic file system
amazon s3 is a print storage that can
store and detail detail from anywhere
websites mobile apps and yogis and
thoris and sola and can easily use amazon
s3 to store and the tied dee the is a
historic humps store and the two any
amount of detail from anywhere what it
features like flexibility and managing
detail and the expensive politics pro white
sandy security desk pro white amazon
simple stories of was already s3 is and
storage for the internet and pleasure to
measure is a cloud storage service
that use for outgoing detail and land om
backups and displeasure is and if i
european extremely large cloud storage
service for this archiving and long tom
backups amazon eps amazon elastic
boxtel prowise blog store williams for
the authorities or ICT and therefore elastic
blog store is highly available and
reliable storage williams candy and
patch to any running instance that's in
the cm oval ability sun eps williams en
orchestras the ec2 instances
alex post is a disorder williams dat
process of elimination of the lifetime of
instance and amazon elastic of system
or service provider and elastic my story
which can be used with elias cloud
service and the socials the rand ramses en
amazon elastic file system is a
simple something is scalable and elastic of
storage for use with amazon cloud
services and especially grammy's is schedules
is easy to use and offers a simple
interface that allows you to great a
configuration sometimes quickly and easily
amazon file system is button last kiss
kiss on the man without disturbing the
application program frank a
aromatic oil azula and
sumo find your application had
stories de not and ran need no let's
talk about databases de to major en
database flavors amazon aws and amazon
redshift amazon aws in two readers de
process in one and setting up of rescue
and skilling airways logo database in the
cloud and scenarios prophecy
conservation and resizable capacity
alarm time-consuming from my shirt
all such as hardware professional
dj setup hedging and backups this kind
free 6 for managing the hardware and care
of health leads to focus on the
application your proud cost effective and
resizable and ours optimized for
memory performance and input and output
operations not only that it also from
its most of the services like taking
backups and a monitor and material
that god him its most of those services
amazon leftovers arms sundridge it is
it did became housing service levels
users to analyze the detail using sql en
ado business intelligent tools amazon de
shift is and fixed and volume nature
data warehouse city mix it simple and
cost effective and read all detail
using is in sql and your existing
business english into spiral
applies long complex and
antiquarian and no stars by a
structured data using sophisticated qua
optimizations and nice fabric out there even
the clear make a sikkens
alright let's quickly to about some or
services that therapies soffers daryl of
moses die plus provides better look at
some more service is the rough guide us
and glass application discovery services
help enterprise customers
plan migration projects by gathering in
imagine a bear on premises data centers
and training data center my gosh and kan
and a thousand or more workloads off and on
that play store dependent selfie
playstation detail and the potential
mapping of importer oil first up and
migration process and dc questionable
application discourse on collection and
presence consecration usaid and go
detail from your service to help you
better to stand for some loose leaf
the three is and network and content
delivery service is and go to you
valuable and scalable cloud
domain name system or dns service and
amazon that friedrich is fully compliant
how we taipei bisexual elastic load
balancing it's oh so and network and
content delivery service elastic load
balancing aromatic distributes
incoming applique centers fact a cross my
guitar that such as amazon eat the profit
somewhere containers and eyeglasses I know
acted wearing the lord of job lukas
I trot in a single and on your such and
old so on scratches dirty it isam cut
blues parents killing it manager
application and aroma die clique jazz de
capacity the immediately steady and
predictable performance and lowest
possible by using in ows everything killing
is easy to share a publication skilling
for mike dose across multiple services
in minutes auto scaling can be applied
to web services and also for the bee
services english identity and access
management there is an ability to manage axis
second bioservices and social security
using a yes you can create and manage times
plus users and groups and used by chance
to allah and denied access to the blitz
resources and more words a free service
hardly talk about the future of
english well let me grow something
cloud is here give some in store
for you be used in the future eyes us by
phone or a variety of cloud applications
by like a tutti artificial intelligence
business intelligence so far less
computing' and selon cloud bloso i
exciting on the market it's like share
banking space arm edgar's and so on earth
was my chicks on time by blood or
greater focus will be given to
artificial intelligence and eventually
the coast of flexibility and add want
something that cloud provides started sea
life company smoking and to the cloud hi
guys let's not talk about how the see
this is to apply and web application in
the cloud will be the scenario here is that ar
users like a product and the white helmets
knowledge and dorothy input from them about
the likes and dislikes and the one i'll give
them the trevor project s partner not
although the setup and the and run my
have the same lux complicated to be done
be the walibi mosque bios flash tool
technologically which can help to achieve
and knowing you so this is like how to
be social icloud watch easy to s3 and
lots more and all the spot together
economy game and application that
elephant hug and the and application
discussion the information like using the
service is like growth for free tri
cloud watch in situ nfc million claim
application and that's cono mi thar not
this is how euro bakes ugly warm oil one is to
apply and web application for a project
that keeps a user's updated about the
opening sentence the new comics in the market
and the full of these came and the gyrus all
services did not want easy to here is used
for producing the computational power
need and for this application and easy
to heaven was when your family and
typestars weekend back from for the
thai of workloads and pretend for the
intense or the workloads for our king
us3 for storage and s3 provide any yes
die san storage requirement for the
reviews all religions all stories
warm for the web applications and world
yvonne hjoed cloud awards for my ring
those in ram and and cloud word monitors the
application and the and why am I the
provides trigger for skilling in en
skilling old infrastructure and again
to do and use you will find 3 for dns and
rivalry 3 money sister better the pastor
morar web application and whether it is all those
tool the technologies together all of
them put together we go him me and
application and perfect application dat
gifts ar not hi john the reviews
elastic beanstalk for this project en
in the take of the application is
gorgias je sea jazz zainab and the in
drummond neem is just the sign up and ram
and one lumiance on i and take realize
this take both the orchestra that code
real domain names they ran I dat and
the application that ahm is can we
hello jean-philippe me that platform and
lunch niceday elastic beanstalk so
a lunch and instance to launch the mood
ring set up of the monitoring en
drummond something I could load again
balancer as well and it's gonna take
care of all the security features is
not it for this application
a reasonable time over seabelt a
great that you know how it is what the game
and the something now I have and that full board
admini all that independencia for the
software is install and issues within
formica upload the code on a specific
de pedro and selected a
la mia protocol and rehab de croce je
grass micro
tablet condition time or on it has done
it strict and now your fico de de samuel l
nice day ambien throne and ado that is
my beach with sofie sign out my take
email and material that your iphone
receive information
and so can send an email to earn there
is that somebody' and subscribe to your
service that they have the full feature of this
app lure that motor nursing dat
somebody subscribe yo rap and the star
e-mail address or like that not only that
is also going to create and entry in the
database and bowels baby is the service at
this application uses to store day
contest modern mowgli and and feico
tables and guides and lucifer en
username samuel and centuries later so and so
hey seb ok oha shown in trust in the
profile or my site or product like this
is wild is highlight collection box
information bright and supporting both
the infrastructure it's elvis
etc running the high and load balancer
lure get it has created to load
balancer the infernal creator and car
scaling group after the feature or tricky
load balancer army cap loose grass herbs
and otherwise killing group and now let's
put this i would you see so be this
all the fancy were already and amazon the one
you all and dynamic you are so let's
ponders the wild mihai and all dns leds
do that
support services colora efteling
goro' station and there we can find the
dns neem brides-les-bains teens neem
never
flat screen entry
and map that the will to a load balancer
rate and create a technically if i go to
this you while widget i admit that
application
alright work that hi went to my custom
while and now that's pointed to my
application free with lead application
with a finger on the moral and now have
and customs
this is how we get tall we start the session
with what is an oil also want that
features and tools technologies
production time interiors provides en
do you want to walk down the hall and the usb gamepad
successfully make a game difficult that the
benefits and features or an alias in the
app and how jewish look that some of the
services as set out to this provides and
random and then mowgli called services and
talked about them like easy to
elastic beanstalk light shade
blondeau storage city nice that those
jewish look to the future of republic
is what a blouse school in the store for
as wind on the dead and then finally
want that allah in which we've created
and application using elastic beanstalk
and all three did laundry and couple
or clicks and boom and application or share
available that was connected to the
database and 30 is connected to the
simple notification system that was
connected to cloud awards there was
connected to storage scale the end
becomes is young was the pink cloud service
provider all like you cloud them
computing' sheet removed at
microsoft now it's basically an online
portal to which you can access and
manager so season samus
well the social sauce between notting but i
know you history yoda and you can shines
of the did to using so is that
microsoft write a can all you need is the
internet and be unable to connect to be
if you could then i get access to our
social on the sometimes in case you work no
more about how it's the frame of mits
thou allegiance rather blue ssd subtle
can the jabra gonna and was that in the usa
was there so gio videos so i got a
clothes of the gutter booties cloud service
providers from the friend family had
well here some things that you're not enough
barger in devoured your February
whispering and this is say and that
members
den rhine in obese was launched its free
to start and harepepper our mother with you
mid black az before you need to be for
the south sea you choose your and more
than most important selling points is
that idea was a fortune 500
companies us as yo sam is something least
the mustard a tough company it
will be July 8 greg comment using if you
and then when you collide highbury die or
programming languages ​​expose the cia
yellow and so much more and other very
important
selling point of the year is diamond or
that that's one so i hate them scratched
well i see signs for the cloud service
provider how cool is my idea so
there answer was the least thick provide
services to fly the arjen well as boys
[ __ ] so far it's killing in the cloud
service provider houses the moment i
expects to manage her mess in a
from which brings something by the number
four twenty commons the fifty for now
with sticks bart as jos amicis well as
you would shame them I in category is on
fashion access this would make them so that clearly
Congo twelfth I had so is that possible
compute and miss lanning integration
management tools he thinks he der
waalsweg and sometimes you have to have mother
hard time time the nice I do more than
pas yor that's a power and if it doesn't
count now your child of the ardennes de
walking on her eyes i speak to feel it
stand with the computers what you
perhaps
we the service budget I do is the
does a watch create a machine or linux
or windows operating system something in
chili con further reach arami ping de
crisis window your chin hardcore age movie
half it is possible in the maker second
after stepping out the second home builds with
cloud service well we so you can create
an application mean the cloud and below
the couch off the youtube light deploying
the application that this is taking care
of by on which includes china
provisioning the application
load balancing and charlie dat die
applications and then it and around via the
teams and handed by your next up let's
talk about would is factory now the juice is
factory the process of them looping en
microsoft is 3d simplified will you mac
the one ring discount promotion and microsoft
microsoft basically and application met
opportunities fabric narrower applications hairdresser
together
next up functions took it functions
youtube geert applications in the
programming language that you throw and then
i do it again in barton park is that you
don't have to buy a bar and i highly
Kants you do hardwork window you
require a comment stories the quality
is taking care of by azure a unique one
the provider or does your and relax cute
and you do hardware is in it ie
just barely to brush networking
services
bottle top pyjamas jorssy die and oil
comes in that louis network well the one if you
if idea and sam is is basically for
delivering
web discount the users well
discarding is of skype and wit and can be
transfer or can be delivered to any pas
to become a scratch now those are action
lee and network of compose place in
start jack precision she be scratched
so the customers can op in so do you
then he is fixed is fixed
next up we him accessart well we did you
can a free connect your eyes that work
on to the microsoft cloud video de
Zeeland station to private connection zo
that oil communication is the ports
operate your own eyes code and the
service that you would then i yes what you
neck now book the merchant network you
can't tell her if that coat coat is like that
communicates with each other in a
bit of months in the private but
next we have like jordi ns like jordi
unisys in craving would is puja love you
too hoster die and essor domain names
system remains one zsa su jin ho's
therapy kissing using as your dns now
for the story sauce is probably on who had
this we store this stories jordy my
brushes victim action of using ad study
or sunstroke price that coal long with
your watcher machine based on your
clients and their blog to reach now these
case your optima is to ensure the
blankets store ma cimmermans or as an actor
that the witching color texts that
elephant by the next hour of five storage
with is a manic 5 stories and can be
accessible where you get the smb protocol
opticell a message blog.com and finally
i love you storage like you stole it you
can provide you blue message you for an
extremely large workload and the most
important but is this can be accessed
from anywhere in the world well late
amber hello you can be used free for a
position the work with fitz qb not
appliqués muslim web applications are you
can death the obligations i keep my
inbox
you can host the application on internet
you can create whatever your machine place and
mentioned before
winters thomas you created that is
watching machines or in the size of window
that you live you integrated in sync
features you can collect and store
mattresses temple of the game that works
keep each other in detail is keep your cut
groupon there all those this possible the
services and your watch my life which is
an extension of the washing machine with
the services are able to provide you a
large amount of storage when they can be
stored talk about a chair ingrid lang en
fun and happiness front wheel that sucks
and [ __ ] rolling services in new
york when this could be one of the best
video can fine in internet and we then
any further delay let's get
everybody likes story put them let's get
started history in a series macho far
away so ham' plan bow spain scampi
globally and cold won the site die
brush for a night i opium and this guy
is within the company for a long time and
so be in the root the company ze
in leon's wife and no girl and the
questions what what i for juice and he would
have good news and bad news for
a single global and nice touch with the
good news is and so we want to know now
who can one of the world's largest
shipping company and the by use case
do we keep all data centers him gays
long out of space and setting up nuance
countries would be too expensive and
very time consuming well that keeper fast
that schools mike die explains the
situation from how i sold by the seo en
then sam come on construction how you with
known to push danny and site are then
what em all that might have come on we de
solution for the problem and it
school microsoft azure
well my keys and hardworking and highest
ai die professional working for the
company where you don't spend time online
the latest technologies and justice
issue video leslie hope will keep
roll up and the cio begins to play all
your de mike candys touch how it is what
cloud computing' and danny design and
talks about your and the sauce is already
football shirt and wire is bertha die
had cloud providers and become the mercury
comes most that uses your and had god
ben fotoclub en and i want it all up with
the use cases of a show
sorry begins with explanations a
microsoft azure is known as to cloud
service provider and it works on the
base saas cloud computing'
then microsoft azure is family known as
windows azure and is microsoft public
cloud computing' battle of is also
provides a range of cloud services and
loading some of them my computer and all
tape storage and networking already started
weather [ __ ] can choose from the services
to download and skill publications by
the way i plan on running in system
applications in the public cloud
microsoft azure is boot and ceiling sms
and infrastructure SMS
let's not fred declaration out and let's
talk about
what is cloud computing' at your services
offered by show how is your loan won
from peta the cloud service providers and
be the companies are using your let's
talk buddha in simple times cloud
computing is bing i need the actions
computer services like so is stories
database networking
software and ali takes in counting jeans and
lock nicely over the internet witjes de
cloud we the flexibility behind
socials that we are bad here
long boxes and used one
and I him so much in media t any
time for an avatar
the so I would be a saint-dear tyler zo
are not pay for it and we'll be so
the title idea only for the services that
we use and this helps gray tea with the
department fixed by anna infrastructure
more efficiently and scale and run my
up or down depending on the business
news and chinggis
and everything about his storage is a
databases and networking always access
to the network of humor systems of remon
computers posted in the internet it
public oil in the providers data center
which is also in this case
well how we do you say neo risks so we
had an anagram is so you know how
silent muse physical servers and grams in
a hosted on a wide web all physical
silver
what we're all in the providers and bram
and dna jumpsuit pan premises or in our
datacenter be only access them to moby
dick looks and feels icm i say for the
[ __ ] up bra and and remote location
reactions teeth mowgli by oldebroek
remotely and wendy then weekend shut it
down and not pay for the ze summerlee use
cases
some of the use cases of cloud
computing' upgrading applications and
services dab use cases ar malfunction by
using cloud for storage alone here this
is wanting them grow they look like musicians
the storage and new day this is a new one
storage war and the aids mare who
to mckids willy hard product and the if
i go out and by and in storage
capacity at flank and tilde use the
storage capacity foil
idm historian in one direction way
discover his stand I and go for a story
which killed and a weekly that in the
cloud what story job met the blow
npo now for hobby your story and for the
next monday the hd liter of life starts
on fire orbital tutoring for him so too
work that namely storage in the cloud and
late of companies and getting benefited
from
failure detail in the cloud because of
it
which I took a nature and the post that
comes along how it and the qi parse.com
as long as we count and make us so fat you love
the provider like your the game demo
application for free the promise en sle
hello wdd history in the cloud this one
lessons learn touch village and partly op
prowein baby koalas s a case
samsung go as long as it's a sickle this
why they do list or your had mydigi
mixart d2 double from the dead end end
of a dog's is whitehead appstore of the
time i chose try eduardus cried
diana use case for all your is hosting
websites and running gloves
using the computer is to disturb beer
music and letting you use cream
the music when you read a book zhou's
store
music and stream the music with the
benefit of
me see the en content delivery network
which allows as to stream
video and audio files which i know
covered with all shook up
audio or video at location wat
seamlessly chose the ark provider to
decline target adelaide in c and therein
pros the customer experience for an
application
if your computer is is a good place
benefits nutrition software to the
months of live software and works of
twitter and kim by using your and
everything a web page I do anyway
moodle so anytime any so actor known
by old and in minutes at the software
for the nexus one love got to war de
let's say and use them and then pluto
just white queen ann bandini
your licensing post by all your
computer services he is and note whether
lot of grass with the which we can
analyze get up google glass in of what's
going on in and that would be clowns
offer performance that matches the matrix
innovation from looking at large and
socialize and time to download again
that plaster and pass them along the pfc
if your analytic services helps to get
angry wonder what score name internet why
am i love when he may increase of what's
cooking with the major
driver will be the top ten hi sleek up
in both in the application
dust long that box can be easily get
down from the all your analytique
services well cloud is willie and work
full time for the internet and good en
love you would be looking back
anytime and any detail gramm ben
milou martinot
holding up one's for you simply dry red
cloud lifelog shampoo and mee jets and
came to a person in my country
person and the other country the lamp
things happening in me forces to de
timing in December
the time get buses history bad guy
henry and the the simple and easy way of
putting it in a picture is in good red
cloud and on the one and one person your
destination that mail and anja thump third
person bleed the email so she echoed
want cool show for that internet after
sam basics about cloud computing' note
bogeymen store construction cloud computing'
in general let's talk about microsoft
azure house and cloud service from
Microsoft Azure is a shelf cloud
services to will manage and deploy
applications on a network we the help of
microsoft azure fanbox and microsoft
azure
computing' service created by microsoft
basically for building testing decline
and managing applications and services
true and global network of microsoft
my once this is in home now master
your pro white sands switches software
as a service
a few switches platform is a
service and the us infrastructure as a
service and they support manager of
programming languages ​​when they were framework
and those tools and frameworks influence
boot microsoft specific and then to
party software
politics and branches build specifically
general management service
if your automation pro white ow for has
to automate the man wants long
landing and frequently peter tosh de
family the fantastic bones cold and
enterprise and rattle AIDS is life time
and increases the legality and I knew
gibson group at ministry of control and
schedules had the bag medically
public of the on a regular basis
the ghia coupe christrio from microsoft
azure ii plus launched on february 2
2001 and it was also be by it was
code and industry leader for
infrastructure and platform is a
service by edgar quinet oh god it's the
housing research and advisory company dit
microsoft your support and number of
programming languages ​​flyte station
diego and item everything is cool services we
get the use and they only for a much you
go threshold reviews for anna biondi gtp
for marriage or list system of
apple reviews and especially how to live for
that booty call and then we got no more
billing different kind of mig had to
and microsoft azure guess credit sales
mole end of the regions and founder of
like this
it's quite easy for eyes to pick and
region and lost ark roasting android
applications from only from day one
because the infrastructure meets the tools
and technology is needed to one or
application of the available always
love purpose is go with the tightrope in the
portico region billy computational lunch
is in politics religion and they be
keep calm starting the one love
pico's airport idea can be another
word weekend I am absolutely design oh
and change the provider pay latency
services to your customers but at
inter or a two soldiers center let's
say and customers will help to al
clearly west which have all the way of
other yo the week recently spend euros
food and they had site on the plans
and decade seemed like a c2 than I want so
you that facebook the bill and datacenter
and here
each customer location mycosan de cost
in one body shop is possible
if your oil house data centers of the work
and all that we have to do is to speak
address to fill and the ram and the whole
lot pours into debon amber one and keeps
so the closet is art therapy 7 the
microphone using a public cloud in sit
off and physical infrastructure so so
box of customers from my way the location
and the services the review is derived
is everything as of now and you speak
need customs glass services
drain and the d chip two different
domain love la forme sweet en
technologically and pennant with a die
anciaux console rotterdam i the talk
about that little in the section zo
carbohydrate two talk about it with for
now she's know that we have led to 100
lessons services offered by your let's
not talk about the france service is a
boarding house white artificial
intelligence glass machine learning
although to whom him live tools and
technology will be wide range of
services and rumble and azure influence
artificial intelligence plus machine
learning plus analytics oven 60 get en
on the glass and group which will
hold off did a car audio publicaciones
performing where the tribe over the
category by details show and clinics
from the along and we reached your computer
services the friends pm how sweet and boring
are the April system
the for a containers a lot of the van
table databases and web
alarm bells posted on a valuable for as
and identity service to go and manage
all users in the edge your cloud and ado
users can be integrated or fat32
alex in google facebook and linkedin ze
the as a mixed all foundation services
the can be used to integrate with an
identity system itil die services arjo
which tools and technology they want to do
and management tools to manage the users
to creating and in the design and
managing them on top of it is and
totally different
tank and who allows him technologies to
manage the users
cool services for in-detail migration
and migration is now made simple tools
and technology both above for mobile
application tablet my and icon plan
my macbook in the cloud route
networking services like and implement
my home security boot if you have a
provider and to barley security services
anciaux cloud that's not possible and
large storage options available in the
cloud too bizarre jill strip who left the
big the list of services on bilbo en
as your cloud so we are glimpse of
what they want to call in the cloud
let's talk about the services in
specific glitch computer for example
when we're building and job location
earth climbing the sting was that from your
computer service provides the
infrastructure
how and a the too long and maintain an
application we can easily trap and de
capacity as your cloud service house en
weekend scale-out compute requirement
under my we grand container eyes and
application we have jakson or using
windows or linux weather machine type that
the want age of the flexible options
if you were god surprised my great ideas to
all your and lots more and this computer
she like and found colors flashed
identity soyuz and mini integration with
active directory in the cloud garden on
from athens and lots more
lets look at self die shows that this
computer my provides some on the
service is the computer microlight sar
root machines and that's like eurogenes
game has the ability to group and manage
and watch your computer and back to my
viper root fear and drum mouth
in dull and the azure cloud in the edges
add in a which will
private network mobile talk about which
private network and members point barcelona
lust and node and the ladder service is
available in all your computer and with
that i can get benefit from
league whale choose from a very wide
range of computer options
free sample and oh we have an absolute
use the operating system that gives him the
option to choose whether this system
should be in on premises or in the cloud
or just put the commons in the in drummond
bid in on-premises and in the cloud phd
option of using the operating system
do we want to win our health and safety production vote
need him software the touchpad
speeds do wanna go and by the
opening system from the cloud from your
market place a bizarre just a few of the
options available for a swim living by
the computer and we're on my and die
scampi rembrandt my sar easily
scalable opinion week in ethiopia
at least from one in since the breaks
or food machine in and matter of
minutes or simply put in a couple of
booking clips and all the services at
red bull anna g for some reviews model
opinion that's another brush who users
and pay for the services that be happier
a thousand no little light on' commitment
with it comes to using wedge machines in
the cloud
the most of the services as built on
paper
minute billing bases
drives and it no time i chose on the pepper
minute billing model at no time we will
be offering for any of the service is that
that she is tractor and all this talk
about bar service
now that service is so is independent
that is or use windows linux is long
family does and the what boxer is
weekend ticket because age of the un blomen
June features and not only that in short
the boxer is helps like the manage the
source at general arms and us to in
helps between you just now this is your
badge so it is absolutely
runs on a large scale
cable a high performance computing
because of that much jumps highly
efficient in angers and ben miranda
service is so if your bed creates and
pull off computer notes and the authorities
the new application is now able to
long and then it kill you jump to box
individually never in flushes our
customer that's not for art yet
all brushes hear that is not for the
orthotics software the lid i can use
to jump marie van de man in barre
wintry times through syntra station die
your software gravity and manage the
body shop and this bed show with is a
platform is a service
there is no additional charge for using
this but she shows except for handling
charges that is not afraid of the carrot
machines that is the celsius and the malfunction
state would be using posted and the de
networking solutions that will be using
for this page even let some guys this
box office for that hubble charge of
training system now i can and
news and the skills by itself name and
title for the but you give us but in
cues o who helps reproduce and paper
for the printer structure residents of
using in book wit and batch from ebay for
some news and so box office helps so to
manage and the application manager is
killing house colette
oldies because in as next one in the
computer my let's talk about this
factory so is that is factory service
is actually and distributes the system
platform that helps scp teams deploy and
manage and scalable and battery level
microsoft and containers and what is it
help the dairy service helps size
or a hampstead and ran there are n minus
2 so so fat and
of wine de the complex
infrastructure problems and they can
focus on implementing what loads of
taking care of the tablet moment against
over and over application nintendo
spending time on anthracite [ __ ] like
elvis factory service factory it
provides long time and capabilities and
the lifecycle management tool
applications die compost of my car
service is no infrastructure management
and must service factory week and lies in
the opposition to cancer hello sorry men
this as some kind of machine
sander candies and containers
ethnic sting a computer men let's talk
about what you machine skins eh well
carrot mission skills at lloyds as the
create a group of identical load
balanced woods and this one to mention
it again it helps to manage and group
article n load balanced whovians
the number of instances the name colonies
at least once in
and that one skills at cannock chase order
greece and response to the month
in which the sponge triskelion that defined
cut in the nose to a man who
Manning is not the same as a true
director ai ai
satb
old sunday morning we take must de
d-day the soos is that we down in the
inside things on the business hours to
the like time that shouldn't go to it yet
an or in a story by my in the
evening so the mask absolutely baby in
den paralyzing and the skills there money sauce
click on the wedding the man's arm out
I about that the flynn infrastucture
requirement at and this a scan your throne
the debtor the microbes man that area
be here one is the skills and also
allows to provide high yes ability to
their applications and help us to
configure centrally managed on date
and large number of areas
sed
the in between wanting to you might as
well which will machines are now why we
need and watch and skills it's logs en
the so root machine skills and help
chaz oh it upgrade your review and
influence performance for applications and
those obligations can be actions en
load balancer auckland is teams had
request to the obligation authorities zo
in a nutshell so you may want to
skills at eye gel chose to give a large
number of identical what solutions number
one and the white skills and read and
increase or decrease the root machine
with carrot maybe skills at week and
central imaan inch and can figure and mdp
group of liam and the integrate use case
win and comes to big date allah
container witlox he is next thing in
computer on my let's talk about cloud
services now this as you close your is
essentially the platform is a service
and it's barry family in fact that is
designed for applications that supports
chilly blog your and application that
require scalability and reliability and
when on top of it be one them to be very
expensive
dropper excel martial cloud service
providers all those both we so
cloud services are wanting to force such an ovm
what is the platform is a service
pm sarro infrastructure as a service and
when we're on applications on liam
dry ass anyway micro's platform sms
of you so i would be thinking with
infrastructure as a service like grams
who creates force and can figure who and
back to mint and then anyone else
locations on top of it lets be
responsibly the responsibility for
awesome who a crime who perjure
editing and te and live in a reply new
patches
picking the sausages or the pudding
system and making sure you're a intact
en oled star futsal managed by warande
contrarie how the platform is a
service
it's a mandate size dnw the bracelet is
all dj who hated all that doe is the
plier applicationnet and manager platform
and my manager ceiling ladder to
ministry biko them in all this time
station is taking care by your life to
the plan you were us on that on ring system
it will biorb him whoever the blog
application and manage the application
that's it infrastructure management is
lever by your zo what is cloud service
provider so cloud service providers and
platform where i can write the
application choir and who is it
whiteboard hartberg city and the wilco den
cloot showa's-tex they gave noah that one
the hardware it on so responsibility
eyecatching what do you do something
scratches we had update freezer bag
did we have and manage the maintenance of
the downtime
india the long infrastructure
or app is trade buy now you're able to
provide and the by the testing and how long
one the front axle and whether I in simply van de
core tested before it actually study
production already an expert upon the testing
obligations so so if your blue is like the
bye filip [ __ ] als and staging and again
to my for testing and you release
how the old effecting that excisting
release how the range
the customer downtime so we go from the
application tester than any damage ready
for action on let's not pre
matter must production is simply do
what the staging in your arms in today
production and especially mouth and that oil
production and back on with will now
become the newest thing in world with
baby can add more to attend and sleep by
executives point if i can the news is
a lot of sleep and back to my for
testing for applications and not only
that uses money monitoring and loads and
helps to monitor the money and avec le
tikal for application and this is it
dashboard weekend benefit from when you
use of your cloud services and that
shows the case study sticks all in one
place and start like sara prio time
lords just one so with love beauty of
a sudden matrix that ow arkansas the bout
that glitch ethnic sting a computer man
let's talk about functions to functions
arthur ls computer then many times you
heard about the also behold lesson
life time they are fencing the person
stockings reference dose
computing' orangery functions which is
so far less computer service hosted on
microsoft azure was the engine
my function is the ex lead and simplify
application download with functions helps
sister of cord another man with old
oh who isn't oh creeper oh vision armani
senior infrastructure
sizer functions
ar script of appeals court
the jets lang in response to when i went
letter i wanna haves solin shard week in
the silk cord that you don't for
problem and them with an action what
built-in god application al dentro
search database running up that goal en
the best of all the best is when you some
things i only pay for the time that our
core compulsion
like function and sprinkle what is if you
functions provider higher functions
online users to build applications using
soul is a simple functions become
programming language of our choice in the
comment program glenwood cerrar
support it's richard f char take note
mugello and page free secure we want
then oasisbar will benefit from my
dating service is quasimodo's chorus
yes all your function handles for it
provides the hd fast had socials not
out at the choir and the best buy this will
only pay for the amount of time de
functions ar and i took the social but
the amount of time the function is home
is next in and beautiful the new domain
let's talk about the container domain in
azure to the container domain of de
container service shop windows to quickly
deploy and production reticle it is of
dockers residential cluster never the container
it's container it's under the universe
software that packages a choir and everything
the tights them the applications one
quickly and the lively from one
computing' and hot and ready for adam i
could be and testing to staging push the
looping each model we then my the staging
the production to from one direction
to the production another wrong with
the cloud or icloud and on to the cloud
weiss weiss up now imagine two years and
half in my body wmn jeans focus on the
application well that's exactly what
containers helps as such i thought this
container instances in even loads
focus on applications a man some things
what manages who gets him so hard
built-in
load the new tools require an age de
wii you and for your and deployment and
applications and recreate dr van in a
container and of the container is
helps to achieve all these would be able
to manager at leading to manage your
soul machine will send these containers
they can be deployed in the cloud
using a single comment using
command-line interface and a couple of
batting clip zip hoody are using the all
your portal andy's containers already kept a
lightweight
but they articoli secure password to
machine just stuck on container service is
next I had that container anyway from
some time squad so sure you win so
so is in health as to manage the
containers containers one thing and so
with dad usedom island the container is
and everything went to discrimination is already
ecs here helps to manage the
containers they les i spande on this i
bet it is at your container anyway resy
is it in action duplo wow from the
simplify the creation lets aggression and
management or the monastery or root
machines the rat rick a figure of
container right up locations on top of
them and deploying him the plugins
containers maitake equal 15 to 20
minutes of the plant the root machine
deadline containers in the white aqtif
10 to 20 minutes and once the operation
who in action lee managed by using simple
knife sets hello internet and daisy is
get used to grunge applicazione glanz
applications from docker images become
put it in the dark images mexx shirt
at the applications the container lines
of foil portable images for portable en
the once us also helps to buy arcenstraat
the container and we with not only that
might also helps to ensure that this
application that belong in containers
can be scale it up as a sorry and
tens of thousands of containers put them in
a nut shell
managing and existing obligation in the
canteen of running it using gps ovcs is
really easy on that was it's all about
to make the application management of
migration easy after managing the container
beast architecture and be discussed at
and canteen scooby sensors from tens of
thousands of containers managing them is
made simple using this container
services quite a training too man using
a large this set in a complex and the
soos intense hnw loom band the gps money
was to simplify
dates in your country are friday next thing
in the canteen domain let's talk about
container big history with pokémon
registry and little bit of peace books
where doctor image zoo container registry
she single place where we can store your
images which at baker made us when i
use when you use them container the roof is there
i made his debut for a remix poppers is
so these container images ai at central
bridge tree that can be used to is
containers and run with bboying de
storage and management of container
images
so derek and
store we already know like
dockers one of the major shows en
dockers walmart and cabinet is editing
can be stored in trentino registry in
azure
well établi store and cantieri make it
provides and option for your application
what that crime week innovation manager
single
registry replicated across multiple
regions
now this job application the absolute
both as to manage
global supply man and xiumin who's there
having a good time and that requires a
global supply and stuff in the help center
manager global supply man as one and the
typical wiar gio replicating who would
be updating wie editing of en mage en
than a magic kids applegate this forest de
global application centers you have set
up and so there is some editing
be he walks learn to the global
images and those global images will get
producers with the global application zo
man edit replication end and processing
of the applications
global white and this web application
us so helps to help with network
alliance see consciously
any time and application that should
apply this mode have a rely on a
single source which can be
giornate roy latency network the course
will have global dedication Zeeland
the war anytime diable pick a wound
check box
you do check back on the application
earphones in a very near by location for
the application at self blog application
crime who or managing it as a single
entity that mean replicated at cross de
multiple regions in the wages
he is nothing to collect learning let's talk
about if your databases well so if your
databases had a race 0 in far we
have a many famous and then I'll keep one
counter the points can be read if ie
cool nautique who cares time of their
base d'un jour off there as long and
when the time war violone one by one
so this all your sql databases and
regional database in factor tissue
database as a service
AIDS managed by all your we do get to
the love of management and just kind
tissue database cheese and service hbs
by microsoft sql server database
engine and this databases
high performance database this is whether
the light blue and the two that is secure
yes and this high reliability
high performance and for this high
security redon got there doing it comes
along we this and the x managed by her en
der tooting heavy that technology doesn't
the machine builds the as your sql database
who is is an intelligence is number
one is foil manage my eyes york and the
dancer des langues tank [ __ ] and
has built-in intelligence deadlines and
patrons canada the max is corn or
forming in the liability and data
protection
off the application that something
that's not found in many of the a de
cloud providers off again
chateau la mention it showed us button
intelligence to learn about the users db
status and helps improve performance and
protection and migration of importing
detail is true easy with a comes to all
your sql database of can be readily of
in medieval ii and use for analytique
reporting and the intelia applications
manager at nextec let's talk about your
cosmetics to warsaw cosmeti be is
a database servers that is for note
quality and the widgetts credit the
provider lonely dancy
and the en application the skills that nami
cleo let's kill sleep ran to so if
europe as may be and it globally de
studio lead service and the cement mortar
database
this can be province and and click on the
button this will we had target chinese
profession and onshore cosmo die be in
the age of
in helps switch killing the database nam
i an elastic lee and independently
scale to quit and storage at cross
hysterical and in a yo video graphics
regions
it provides a good to put it provides
for latency provider availability and
then it provides all your promises and
comprehensive is just that no other
words can offer that is the best partner
balk cosmeti silk cosmetics was in
the global distribution and mind and let's
build a how we enter the horizontal skill
my and thus we can use by only been
for what who had him center of the
defense between all your cosmetics and
sql database is that if york was me baby
supports notion koalas is dual digit
refuge things about if you need cosmetic
shop windows used to use case all your graph en
column family and documents it
ever so gives users and number awp
options like sql javascript
molo baby en and 4 others that you might
wanna check the day and the timing
and the barrio the city all that we mention
crib use of the pain for the amount of
storage and junk on that required and de
storage and the junk becomes can die
last crease kill based on requirement
of the dark red let's talk about a red
is cash
discussion about your database would be
completely white old talking about to
discuss now this is tickets
secure something delicate in such as some
time squad and messaging chunks dat
provides high troops den dool agency
access to details for the application
tribe gladys candles based on and a
popular on a thoris caching project
which there is some work or less than
this cache now what the use case is
typically used as an improved
performance and scalability of the
system that olive oil and fry in india
stories and performance when they
discussion group by temperley popping de
freaking comments did that by stuck
storage located very close to the
application well what we candle so
fixed orange is locator in memory how
must the nan desu ka
intro windows from the actual disc in the
database even so this is christmas in our
be used a share his in-memory
structures by after then the third can be
used as and the studio the name already reads
database and and message broker as soon as the
radio of use cases for this cache and by
using this case the application
performance is in group by taking
advantage of the note and the high one
crap on performance at this leather
case [ __ ] prowise so de summarize this
then this cache my muse sandisk sd
there is through in the memory in she loved
is the insured out to this group is
and lo latency of the application no
story that they do it provides medium
level skilling metal in downtime or in
de france now this wedge beige sexy back
by radisson and the it supports all string
vests linked list and who is on the
members structures after let's talk about
security and identity and services
well identity management is specific
a process of authentic the first and
then
authorizing using security principles
and not only their identity management
in residential control
information about those
principal identities
you must now watch and identity principle
nou identity of printable identity ars
office applications
user groups and the unlock more
the special theo bos so identity
management there is huge michiels
authenticate not right prince lager in
cloud it also helps had a the cake en
authority
prince offered sargassozee entre ses
especialy van joran and hybrid cloud en
drum mouth like that and services and
features that the site and that management
access to get a this new level of
validation light energy management
countrywide motive factor authentication
I know provider doctors policy based on
condition or comment the me based on
condition
economic and monetary suspicious
activity and newly diagnosed reported i
can also help and save alert for
potential security issues and in the
white mediate this can be if and everything
so weekend living in and the province and
the security accidents of happening
will let's talk more about identity
management
social of the services other secure a
day and identity management of a your
security center to this all your
security center provides a security
management and web protection too
schedule workloads in boot cloud and in
the hybrid and drummond in helps control
user access and application control
step etymologically active present it
helps to find and fix waller bulletins
before and they can be one x plants
here's a great very well what
analytical methods that helps as to
identify your english as the intelligent
to identify your deck tedx and prevent
and before i can actually have and i
don't work seamlessly what hybrid and the
ram and so are you going to do have one policy for
on premises and one policy for the cloud
aids now and unified er service boot for it
on-premises and the cloud the nothingness
his security and identity would be
keyword nou ik keywords and service or a
feature that helps safeguard the
cryptographic east and in your secrets
used by the cloud applications and the
sauces
in aduard so if you keyhole the they then
for securely storing and icing de
secrets of them were on me and win the
secret pick an hr cycle anything that
i really would have and very tight
control excellent service kit like the
passwords material that now in fight
and you what you were chili sauce dat
word oxley exclaim what keyword is well
ok walter views and cycle management
this helps a lot yogi malfunction the token
is the stagecoach the surfing kids and helps
and key management and also want health
and creating and controlling the
encryption key is that new views un
coup d'etat in helps a certificate
manage
talking about association management
you the helps if too easy pro view and
manage in the fold public and private de
ssl kiev surf kids in azure
and lots more
like that in a nutshell
so keyword i provides users de
politics your croatian was new and choose
in just a matter of minutes of web in
the 0.0 set in a couple of warm clips in
our helps users the central my names
the choose secrets and policies next in the
list let's talk about all shook up to
date 2 well if you rock to that should
even if the create intelligent drive
and access policies to limit resource
usage and manage user identities becomes
so it won't be now so if you hit
u de tri is a cloud based actor busy
tree and identity management service now
all your active directory combines en
aids action your combination of the codec u
services plus application access
management plus hide and the protection
and one good thing about this author
in five dollars of good things but
especially when you're running
hybrid and from whence someone wonderful
how this all your actor christians
understood that is if your october 3 is built
to work on premises and loud and
london tess or nathalie those boxes
block seamlessly with mobile applications
is like that in a nutshell
so if your active directory and access
and central point of identity and access
management for icloud and veranda
it also provides the security solutions
at protect against unauthorized access
of app and they do know that will
discuss about security and identity
let's talk about the management tools
that also has to offer
also provides image and management and
account that we are a tools third movies
to be an administrator
and der loos the autumn and the keeper pink
secure and work compliant and I'm in
hell mocked in on-premises and in the cloud
and burn andy's management tools
help if the monitor monitors the infrastructure
monitor the applications
we dance helps a proof' and can
figure in the sometimes is that she helps his
all dating apps hey help are analyzing
sites checking back up on three so sister
bumps a disaster recovery
he that they health and offline policies
and conditions de artimeta rembrandt
my muse as your management tools and
is also used and cost control much so
this issue management case had white role
cross and the azure sauces and in the
management tools
force comes the edge redwise still there
if your advisor at acs he said guide to
educate earth above all your best
practical lemon police state weekend
select the bases on the category of
service and also provides the impact
I know her for the impact we have
and there and everywhere sir who follow the
recommendations green
and recommendations or post with the
recommendations al ken of template iced
and white pink
the template eyes the recommendations nam
the third goal to provide customized and
recommendations on the bases same
configuration another business or a
huge weapons and these recommendations on
my heart it's not like something that
recommend and then just leave so hang
in there and these recommendations
provider a very easy to follow we de
easy to implement and serious if you
can tank or from show advisor trip and the
aow brush icloud consultation and that helps
shadow fall of best practices to
optimize her the prime lens i can on
analysis' are free songs of
configurations are using and then i
recommend and solution for if you want
help his impey
the cost-effectiveness in proving the
performance in proof high
availability and improving security in
hair as your in the edges
is as good as europe advisor we can get
up proactive
akzo nobel and post best practices' list
recommendations to here and you have
within export just follow the user and
wiser and you ever on this can offer
in our helps improve the performance
security high availability of warm en
treating
and also helps and bring down the overall
if europe and and the best part it is
fries about analysis' arranger usage a
provider foundation I keep an optimizer
if joris east radius costs and facts
costa the same time boost the performance
helps and students in security and
improve the oral reliability waste and
burning
an extra loop 2 be network which allow
this network watcher helps users
identify and gain insights in the hole
at work for my and the money of the oral
and from are now those 6 hour watchers
prowise
in or fine monitor the day was the fell
the matrix and to enable or disable eyes
must love mintage and running and leaked
for eso's is in the air show what you want
network so bid network watcher can
monitor and that glass
issues in networking paid in my
logging into the way to mention switch
it allows you to real time weekend axel
account also becomes a trojan to be in so
than those gbm modern database and all
just looking at the likes and all of you
that is used for analytique what the game
jam intelligence and what's happening in a
network weekend he no ladder insight
to the current network traffic data
using the security group vlogs
that's like watcher office at our helps
an investment wpm guide to the issues
using the trail along now you my door
might not know that and owp and
troubleshooting requires boot parkison
your often tupac is a different person
which just what my cedron the site and the
network and mystery door on the other
side and they will have it large on
there and then you have checked live in
a bowl and stuff like them but what the
network watcher i can head exeter de
next level
the long sits itself who wants easily
identified how boring it is having the
issue and she just an appropriate fix en
the next'll be to be microsoft azure
potter now this microsoft edge module pro
rizer single unify console type from
baby's number of activities like
building on the building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
will now this portal can be used to
organize back and forth armant hda pierre
agree on the and drummond all visual of the
related to based on an artwork style
and using your photo users can control
gets to manage your access to so sal van
theo show bottle
and so if you have polybius and work
visibility another game that have an annie
trees and if i can customize it week en
our identify spence based on team space
space time
this spence base to parliament
dust lab absolutely we know them music
wondering how were money is spent me too
is the balconies boy with a slideshow and
met again
next to do list would be as your own
research manager
well if your resource manager e-labels like
to manage the usage of the application
resources no use resource manager supply
manager and manage solution
dose as a group massive tits one
single and is he now doing the infrastructure
of an application is typical a
medieval encampment [ __ ] and blow
sport your machine stories watch your
network
web app databases
they had to pride services at the mind
you are her and especially wind and dr by
nature
set zipper or 6 bar with as your resource
manager water bottle see them and different
companies all the fun and today is
instead you see them as related services
in a group that supports and
application or i can't get the relation
between them in solo vino letting them
strange human resource manager identify
the relation between them and helps to
visually see them all is one arch single
entity marley that azure resource
manager help sorry in shows that the
social is that who province to the
planet constant rate hello wit the
other application at all to groups users
to visually see their processes and how
they are connected and their helps in
managing the social law mountain
resource group also used to control who
can access the roses how it and the users
subscribers action cam or pushed fine small
control your gets to access and
who does not get access and the last one
won in the management tools would be a
mission and so armi shows like the
evolution the poor eats can figure and in
set upgrades
akros hybrid and from miss it provider
cloud based on a mission and configuration
service mobility this can be applied
for much your and woe from people both
which is on premises sociology had
mission mikado process automation at bid
management on a mission
cumpilation features imation
fabric light up and this as you a
dimension provides complete control
using the deployment operation and also
using the decommissioning of the
workloads and russian to the poor girl
weekend action to make up tank and jimmy
or
mouth or in the house that there is crown
microsof here my everest oosting
scampi poor this sorry respect dopamine
times of the slightly cooler of the cw
and I want to help to using the or all
time and also the or the cosby coastline
the teams measure her arm how it means
it's you are free which means the
application is not walkway can keep
running for a longer period of time
the poor girl week and actually build
a good in montreal pudding sauce
ambrosius and configuration items all in
one place is white and so wanting helps one
[ __ ] the changes and invested in this one
lessons santing have a micro swivel a
mission because it's looking the
cumpilation changes the institute question
easyglide and the for easy to identify
your head change lately that has broken
the one in iran with cuba can fix it hurricane
or trash
that's also follow
and after that chili summarizes the show
management tool for management services
nolet's talk about the networking tools
about the networking services available in
your turn right i of services speciali
networking services such as your office
and onshore
which could be interesting one let's
start a discussion web content delivery
network to the content delivery network
in short sea die and hit ls sidewalk or van
secure and very reliable content
delivery time lapse that they are help
excel in the delivery time out to
the wicked witch using the delivery time
out chocolate stuck lead times roll te
help and saving then wit and increases
and responsiveness to the application
let's x pardon so thick and partly for
the network
is absolutely the stable the network of
service desk and efficiently delaware
web content to users now seriously
we are now going to use with id and here cd and so
store christmas content on global and you zo
is our co s
pop's point of presence
locations that are unemployed to the end-users
so that latency is minimized is like
taking a copy of today there taking
hood you know and malfunction in the
of parts of the world and how we is
requesting just three who share god for
to them from so my [ __ ] wie loco
just left this cd and wash the dishes
galloper global solution for rapeseed oil
we share ring my bell with content i used
by cash and the content in estrade cycles
placed location witches you more
until they get this side and delivery networks
it really helps and act that one en
one d show get front in the living room
network that we can handle spikes and
heavy loads wd efficient link and who
whole country analytic
and services nicest gadgets and running
it in content delivery network which
helps and gaming gear insight on the
workflow and the would be the future
business no de for web application en
So
just like ladder of the service is this
is anna ps i go to show you used his
first and then you only pay for what you
have used
the nexus one and networking would be
expresso expresso old is action you
thought you a link that provides en en
dirk wi-fi connection the york and that was
strongest if you love it and see link
to all your music it speed and
reliability
for those who already show details for it could be
on premise is to your so you zwingli
videos increase reliability and lonely
dancy for that connection let's expand
otherwise the bed and that's experts woman
to be so is that action ran rights and
time and connection between microsoft
data center and infrastructure in our
prices at kennedy from colocation
facility that we might help that 6
plus red
do not go we de public internet en
bitcoins the dongle republic internet
they have high security reliability and
speed and lo latency camp and the
connections
bouchard in the internal
because it's fast week it was like big
o [ __ ] hey guys how latency i can be
used as an extension of harry 16
datacenter well users' and night can
much the the french what the decor action
sing services from and on premises of in
the cloud and especially moment bieco is the
latency is minimized as much as possible
users and rollin on donation de de france
and the grange private line and not and
public internet line it can be used to
build hybrid applications paid
compromise on privacy or and the
performance
that's what you want private cloud
these express shed can be used for
checking back ups of is young and buck
brood to the internet but would be a
nightmare
vuzix fun old for backups dat
colony fixed and the margin we
homes for sale did a true die internet
from the cloud to the internet to the
on-premises in the he was disaster dat
praying was nightmare so that is
express shed can be used for you de
backup of eastern european words detail
because it provides [ __ ] muscles lonely
dancy recording' 3d economy long ze
the nothing projector service or we can
discus in networking is matthew rode in
is now if your dns already off as the host
domainname in azure
and that is pastors camp app and
exceptional performance and availability
well as your dns
is used to setup and manage
serving such a centric arts for ardo
take away in the cloud that is if your dns is
take a service for dinner shetland
six and me providers and a grizzly sean
by using a shows
infrastructure and the by using this
domain week and actually my inch de
dns marcello's through the eyes your
portal of the same prodent shillin major
having a dns provider must have this monument
interest in high tea with and there and
change the we have set red portal de
corn to share have been changed by sargon
and now week and axel i manage the dns
in the bbc as europe rotel we we use
the rest of the other services and this
Season dna playing with integrations becomes
all dns service providers and uses i
global network or take they knew provast
response to dns greece and the domain of
having a death note of all politics
come back to the other domains service
providers availability policies that saw
him morality and the rest because most
of the service and maintained by aan
microsoft and that helps the will
solo this helps rethinking
let's say so much sitting and or phelps
rethinking how it left the
drivers so all that microsoft and weather
on with all microsoft think global
network or take a rest and event shows
dat ar domain name servers old rapper
you that there is now properly desk so
a lot
brush the hair through an external list
in networking services
wrap network on show so we can
again a matter of shirring and liking
she so networking of which will
networking in azure please your applause
if the cells own private cloud
in the public cloud us and isolated and
highly secure and from bent for umbrella
case logic span on this on this all your
watch your network help sauce
province
edgar mitchell machines and that helps to
securely communicate with other on
premises and internet networks here also
helps and controlling the traffic to
flow through or loose in and out of this
world at work to all the witcher
networks and to the internet but is also
a virtual network santens cola suwinet
is actually a representation of all your
network in the cloud is action the logical
isolation of days of your cloud
dedicated to your subscription
all ear and the poor will province in a
who just third set wit from and other
customers who just that who the web
logical separation then this which will
at work and also be used to process owp
human in the cloud so connected this weekend
eeklo and that on-premises infrastructure
and lots more especialy in lnv van mijn
well who him group nv of men shan love
using social network you chose that shoes
require bbm for security plans for in
and out of the cloud and in and out of the
on-premises and edges
heart i will know or us and bam 3
for other sosocio all traffic between
the as your resources thick and of logical
i stayed in between a lovely stay het en
die as your virtual network and heroism
and design the network is new in over
then was quite you can [ __ ] that ipconfig
the routing you can bind was just about done
praise drove and miss gray and rosé
half control remember that network is the
site it's not leksand a law salami
buy and then the use it now are who
its absolute will that your network of the
scratch week impact that ipad is that who
light weekend I was very good just nice
to communicate how we they are some with
physical that and leak set if you are
using hybrid and we that moment i
definitely will be crying and virtual
network the growth and helps connect die
on-premises and the cloud and ethical
fashion using gps the latest project
wrap discussion networking is a
load balancer
so load balancer absolutely provides
application and good quality and good
network performance
they had them two in action works by
load balancing the trof I do a from a
the root machine and the cloud de
sociology that tybalt so load balancer
had between the cloud and the elk race
premises virtual network with so load
balancer week in action is all on
application and create high availability
for car services which means an
application will be available
most of the time video lesson about GMOs
time so about this don't get traffic
weapons the soviets classic users could i
spinning stand and weapons in so over the
smartgraph i user home spire and edam
time the connection is shifted one money
anyway the user experience is uptime
all the time so load balancer support in
beans and the old bean the scenarios app
provides a lead and see if you high
scrap it off the dead man's for and the
week an action scylla de flow or the tcb
and you the connections from 100 2003
from the middle speakers with a load
balancer now in the queen the user and
the application they had them brave so
load balancer absolute seas chart and
the food load balancer the trajectories that
bank and cool or institutions connected to
the park the roll and the hell pro that reset
led would it maintains high availability
so what is load balancer help be help
creation of higher elbow scalable
application in the cloud in minutes and
can be used or a merry
jdm impoverish how it the increasing
application graphics and one feature of
load balancer is to check the hero of the
users application intense and I promote
it step sending the requested a hero
instance and knowledge that connection to the
hell die in stands the two and user all
connection this not get stuck with and en
stands soaked multi-touch olive oil to
know about the networking services nou
let's talk about the story services at
the storage domain in the show well as
your storage in general
is a microsoft money service providing
cloud storage which this gland is highly
available secure double scalable and
then the course kids of managed by you
did and get to manage and love it and
design view stories is poor and group of
story services decatur this a new and
historical productions enclosure blog
switches action an abject range it
influence some of your this seemed in kilos
your fire president lawsuit close and
showed you it includes a chau tables and
lots more but let's start a discussion
with your store simple if you bother
symbol is and hybrid cloud storage
solution that a swim lowest cost of
storage to nearly sixty percent
handles shoeby lesbian i pay
using it like you simple stories
pastor is simple and integrated storage
solution that manages historical bag with
who on premises and the cloud storage
for and really like what you're is dat
slightly bumped edges hybrid and who warming
in me download from the cloud
providers we start home and harbor en
ramming is the big challenge snow in
hessen compatibility i would be defined
and hybrid over entre mis is a cloud
solution for your latest flat bar white
t-shirt specially when it comes to
storage lodge the scariest figure see it
clearly design is the answer to hybrid
and drum mouth in my ear and tablet come
back and talk about store simple and
store simple became fish and
cost effective and engaging and
manageable san storage media networking
solutions in the cloud peter antoon this
information the reason why did store
simple is really big eyes users store
simple 1000 series devices which are
used as your datacenter and this store
simple or simple stories and comes along
how the storage inspection the men
vadesto the details the videos storage
media will give that grant the work gallante
detail is absolutely ear and on-premises
a solid state drive and dna this user
has frequently is stored in a hits die
those so hard disk drives and the de
decadent plugwise archives of the beast
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
oh boy oh boy oh c keep storage
inspection automatic weapons and store
simple and the one and all cool feature
phone store symbol is i in able
guests create in order to months and
scheduled backups of detail and then
disturbed detail garlic oil already in the cloud
and these bugs absolutely thick in the file
or incremental snapshot which means
that they can be greater and restore
quit nits to complete backup bits
and incremental backup and that one is cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important when there is a disaster and
when there is the even record scenario
micro sd snapshots candy color and they
can be good and storage systems and then
they become the actual details recording
is firmer review by rapper
studio make absolutely i have free quant
backups and so story simple it really
helps in easing
backup me knowledge and which means
economy there's a disaster recovery
steps of success is so disto simple
and can be used to automate the
management data migration this moment
director in across the enterprise bod
in cloud and on-premises smart that day
tasted compliancy excellerate de
disaster recovery pre-covenant with
and I this is one thing that thing
grazing avenue dna and back to my that
would be storage and this store simple
addresses city not and who you could
also helps prix plan or think in the
powerpuff girls tori google now we have
a simple stories of a lot in the
cloud and more words on Apr 7 times zo
not much free planning and storage is
not yes he doesn't know what not as much
as a bit of it out the cloud orbital te
simple storage and nothing about it
historical how we like to discussions
what you did seemed so clear
store of stories and cost effective
solution for big data analytics in
specific celebs i spend she is so it
detail seemed stories are enterprise-wide
repository for big data analytics
workload after the medusa was that the
pendent did otherwise seemed store and so
clearly in furniture as the capture
did either any size or a detail and or
a jacket muscle and mtf click voice and one
single space all in one single place for
operational efficiency to
operational efficiency and for and all
types shadow in azure is work depending
on this day that looked like storage and so this
historical design de wit performance
for analytical in mind you know you got it
singular him using analytique in de
cloud great have using the target in the
cloud in the show who bulge to using
only baby to the moss part one other name
more precise order rights to read shop i
what btw lick store in azure the design
web security in my show any time of
use as your storage how week and the rest
assured that be on using storage from met
a and datacenter which has for which
was built
how it security and mind so so this is
tori oso users' as your blog stories
behind the themes for global scale yogic
tea and for performance let's talk about
love stories and blood storage provides
large amount of storage and scalability
and on this blog storage is that one too jack
storage solution for azure cloud let's
expert bitcoin blog storage shed your
blog storage is microsoft or ring for
objects storage on this blog stories is
optimized for malfunction there was a man who
structure date on which could be taxed
arbanassi dt is designed and optimized
for rapid
left your bike plein theo and what
scenarios will be using love stories
that my god pewds yeah dude and the mood
or for blog stories
site-help there is designed so it's been
used in many of them were on mens to
sell images all document derek so far
the browser in helps a failure finance
for the stable behind the live
more perfect scan fett corn spin-off
your blog storage and currently help
users stream video and audio bits kindly
be used for lighting love science something
carnegie be used to store day language as
backup and restore and ran in times
or disaster recovery dead so is users
and archiving storage in blood flow
righty and room which is why i use and
malfunction analytique detail mom who
malfunction where for so long in analytique
we who acknowledge the details show them leds
and why they use case for blood storage
to alida de in it's a toilet we
mention adam's apple boys and me and eat
him summary updates and they do any work
she gets created which means and keep an
eye on road bike path and when in the middle and
the project live flexibility and
optimizing the users storage and no the is
also supports jerry hall the details obs
the harley quinn axel explore how to find
love options hi can pick from that no
sure to my juni storage and we run my
the organic storage no the and leaks
side the store and structure detail and
designs proud details a valuable for
customers to rest base the objects
storage and nothing changes project and
storage vishuddhi qiu's store is not to
storage provides you love you for large
valium cloud services rituals symbol
and cost-effective the double message
you for large what is a flash expanded
is your storage or for moment to disc
your storage service for story large
amount of messages the can be accessed
from anywhere in the world to grace' dp
and https came and single cue
cindy view message can be up to lack 20
for gibi in size and a single you can
contain millions of such phone baby
in size messages and comments it is possible
hear I know hold up to date oil
capacity or historical can even do this
salad's easily know the trance league
comics it becomes dog and so as york
used or is it provides and messaging
solutions control obligations and
competence in the cloud what the hell
from health and designing and application
for skill and helps and that link in
the obligation so content network de
pendent or sometimes it's not it already
depending on the other application
micros well we have cue and the green
witchcraft from slate.com f-connectors
scan of the people boot and that and verant
with well barbecue with your fine
changed and scale up or skilled and
independently the next in historical zo
would be fine storage
that sticks will be fine store is not the
sun shines provider secure simple and
managed cloud of shares well the of
shell in the cloud editorial lakedance de
users like on-premises ordered my scan
capacity and love family tools for the
cloud affair management can be used already
long white and you from your storage tab
white again absolutely sixpence he prays
on a file of storage to this all your
file as long as you file stories office
or feel way of shows in the cloud
and can be accessed via via smb
kale driver message blog
protocol now this also find shares can
be mounted concurrently by cloud of a
entrance mrs deployments love operating
systems el campello windows compatible
linux is compatible with ios is
compatible in and navision to all this be
able to one congress and to the cloud
applications of moncler is wrong and to the
I cloud in our or ready
catching a day time keeping it locally
something like that in mediate legal when needed to
that someone this new feature about it
cda with housing feature that offers kamp
and the to the other side chair software
in the market let's talk about table
storage with star roots tour is not
able storage
nosy crow rival you per storage for quick
deployments with lunch semi-structured
this sets the difference between one
important thing to module table storage
city ​​at home and flexible dh schemes and
also highly available with sex properties and
pray on a table storage she an eat him
just a prick eskimo lesson and no sequel
time double storage is the one will end
up to picking it provides and key pair
attribute storage with eskimo lesson design
this table storages very fast
and we who cost effects for many of
the obligations and of the same amount
or dates
kidslab cheaper of yours is struggling with the
crash steel sequel and detail data
storage
social the Pentecost weekend store in the
double story char of course' did
economy flexible this archit such as a
user data for web application other
books the way of mission and other
types or metadata for about anyway qua
man and i know him a number of gables
up to the capacity limit on the stories i
come on this is not possible with equal
this is only possible we nozick it
mills staff becomes double storage in
azure exploration of storage really
concluded the longitude and latitude or the
splash and so seo
was giving is high tea brush what the
site that is portal but then this has to be yet
i still house and brushes email actor
so length discussion and his issue
was what the ladder what the cloud providers
what with the use specific i choose
your eyes' from the side quest andreas
weekend crps became julius and that i
definitely gerard and became the organ
issues on seo or and then and state x
play about the on the capabilities of
your own house white side or at least the
rest of the cloud providers sorry i
started a new age and started this
discussion but from the phone and well
now czech explain why the
capabilities and how is your is better
than the camp de between g-star met
explaining the platform is a service
capabilities and ambon the hollywood
deseo tool is the ai that person zoso
platform is a service about a
platform is a service that
infrastructure management is complete
ethics and care by from microsoft and
loving you east focus completely and
the innovation
no more infrastructure management
responsibilities
go and focus on innovation that stade
fancy wfc not with your by platform if
it's that word budget weekend
antibiogram
from innovation and not just made and in
the infrastructure and their eyes were
specially
is that my friendly also supported acne
programming language and the in houses
oh it's image or design de tardis
optimized to work some oil and the new
publications de pride using that net
programming fanbox if your application
is the day like a must of the time i
you we and they picking if you m level 2 de
campo most of the time i you we and they
picking grab your glow surface pro air
and the security of rings get your
office is the design based on the
security download moments lifecycle
[ __ ] and industry leading edge ulens
process are you by southwest of jour du
pêcheur city that in the ram and so design
the based on security and download
moments lifecycle and like those people
many times in the post and old like to
mention it again as your password or
about the hybrid and run mens watch
ladder of the cloud providers have a lot
something like the easy to set up and hybrid
de en Weer arm en to migrate de date
ever not my bridges and still long en
hybrid and we are also accountable
seamlessly with your grocery shop pro
white seamless connections cross
on-premises data centers and the public
cloud lancel hathaway the gentle reward
give you look at the you the document
dation the picture rich and de
documentations poor not and two years
for the willy the eat something and do crazy
lord we encourage you to think and
imagine and two easily get grasp of our
services website so very gentle long in
chrome if you allows the playstation of
technology that several business he used
for you so there is a big history behind
it in his way the gentle planning code
between the vacation ze documentation and
this tb always education level is it
will be gentle lonink ruffles it
generally brass no other cloud
service providers to this would really
impressed the video for my people working
in the france and budgeting eva
foundations all the using microsoft
software weekend and the lido and a file
or be bored and as for and discount
webcam reduce the oral pleasure spending
in white solo uprising of new york
jets word helps of the ardennes to
mention that helped the ethiopian your
eyes with cloud service provider and en
the see you go zone and talks about the
deaf and company is off grant lee using
your and the car dvd using if you for
ease and light pixar boys samsung
easyjet
xerox bm taglio tree and the arm major
multinational mobile in camps that is
this line of
operate a high tea in pure and vision
result that your site is that person too
want to work late on the lesson and that
xhose him and visual takeaway easy thing will
in angers sorry design i splash about a
practical application of bonjour watches
rolex xlii and mother show us willing
and mercury project on building and also
using a billing adopted application and
in europe and make it connect to and sql
database my solidify
all the knowledge that who's got one
shofar so this is what we were going to do he
him and if u can open fcc login and
editing is fresh care
corrosion group is notting in their het
scanning fresh bread and login and this
is what we can do
anyway create and application like this
widget load was increasing on location
not to do list application hacks
can run from the way but get
information from as en 17 the database
that connector does it so I know all those
seek to their application we and they be
alright
salami go back to my ass your account de
frost ingestion create and resource group
let's give it and
offer fullname let's go let's go
simply red
and the kobe and free trial and the
location pick one that's a new west
to you
to what extent you won the lunch or
application
now for this use case en european
sentell us and great tits may tyco
fire de get creative theo know something
escola you're simply love now what are you doing
not winnie and web app and and patrick
sql database
let's post i get a web app running
sakura on services and some could out
i got the web app plus s cover
wanyuan web reward for so i samples
let's clean and web and graphic please
let's go let's go
simply to the subscriptions free trial
and other use my ass fisting
resource groups there so scrub third week
already him bang buck
is just old windows and their publish
I also have it when the weekend screams
wine so is home on led may create my
hd base
mysql database
creates and database
which we take with quality you're
simply love baby
products to excising resource group
that week know it scorpion blank
database
right and it may require some
settings like
the take or show and that poor logan
the passport the chose long and and white
location this is colorique so know about
name is walibi
you're simply want to be taught the
surname and the app my login can be
we can be the laughing stock with late
to see
she let's call it simply love that mike
my blog and a
and with that peck fit
click on create whatever he wants so far
greater than web app and bf greater en
it database in the de soos group deadly
have created several rosy glow
it will be me some time the photoshop sophie
tomato sauce group only had one resource
group s well if you're simply tall and
third house
bunch of roses
ambien cries and that still be created in
in the meantime i had my application right
4 dead voltage off for leds in visual
studio and so fast she was a the
infrastructure recipe and freddy
in argens console and who google works
your soul studio or eadis inputs in the
visual studio becomes noos with the core
the databases that the clamshells like
to share baby material that anyway
feed boxes information and visual studio
with that lily feeling it into the
application and then we can of it
from their de plants obligation diks
quite a while i really got to be
passionate
right now we him more chubby social step you
not before the application is here too long
my database
here is my top service
this one more thing we let do that is
great and fireworks option she wore won
draw no that is to create and firewall
exception brother
pride cda-politicians is thin and tall of me
local
death star and it can also connect to the
database hi celebs and an exception
[ __ ] at simply adding decline die pi
the conflict might be dpi or laptop to
using is it well and it can also create
exception to access the database so that
standing now we can go back to do with you
studio 100 go cable or
apps from your goal of configurations
post from
visual studio molecule in the rap
time I do it for the fourth time you
may not be doable
title at city of the scratch
this is we were similar to how you would
be doing a senior and to which one already
oh we do select and excisting all shook
up service well for example ah blood and
as i can see a blood and how it mine
credentials come true profile tanks
automatically from my shadow can so in
this case m can use and existing and
you're a so select excisting
and click on publish
at the factory all these are the very
same pink city week left a while
back
what we clicked on him
and something
roaming can or validating the core and
its can come on what and joanna
initial die url is not good work pico's
we have with the application to the
database that we buttocks next thing
oh so the app has been published and its
home from my own web app is here now
something control never let you see
this stroganoff that's because we have
with that app and the that be together
celestia
he flashed that led scores about explorer
this is where you can see a database
is that tony have created a flat screen
tv that kebab 2
that's like group
mike the prophets service group
on black here
and the here have my
database
you simply line
tip is
when texting connecting to my daily base
team i white moment
let's fix it
it would like cougar that your database
interesting location
koi show let's go to the solution
explosive
click publish
and peter like this kitchen and from
pewds oh weekend guru can figure
here is a web app
I'm already becoming something credentials
leds qualities connection
number one
tight end and click next
this is my the reconnection
string rate which the apes' be used to
connect to my baby
a few ricola db weiss oh help ensure
like a clone that be and that's not been
shown here
she's on fire
hi the Latvian is on fire
the content figure
alex pot arabic about what's for
Which
let's change this to sql server running
and and and very
fetch
babies they become cofactor show is here
mine
who be your scores take
van der geer
Hi
the username
the connector so both that drink
before and
and the passport
we some sports and
but the beach back to all your
portal of the jury infrastructure and
here is my
dbc viticole it's all your puzzle day
Bidet or let's database
test connection
cox and is club
click on ok
so well the station i greatly and you're
simply love baby that the game of the
database
a week left
now something could figure
mine
the motive of the detail connection is
relax folders working on the procedure en
so oh no must the database is if you're
simply line
baby
and then
score 3
you want summer
final details
tar
username is simply van
and the passport is what
who have you am in the peeling
hi let's do it
the connection
xclub
click ok
dismayed and ready to publish location'
the game now the application knows how to
connect to the database we educated him
ate with you the carts connection
strange the dinos take the username and the
fit for obligation to connect to the
database
a lot of studios building this anyway
project and once this up and running hoe
a be prompted
with the and that morel had to connect and
any time you could argue inputs the you
are let's go lucy eyelash and cz in the
database
alright so here is my to do list app
and the mike and
city ​​also waiting to do list for myself
red hot item solid listed by can create
and and 3 and the sentry skatestore and die
you in the database and create and other
entry
then it also attracts for work that's also possible
kate store and coriander entry too
tickets for scientific
exhibition
and we can see that when a product in
the database and target blu eye fashion
show through the section you so how we can
use your service de create web app en
can i that the die baby in stance and how
those two services which are the couple
body for which a separate at the phone
house them in a use the connection
strength to make connection between the
absolutely and that database and
be able to create and working height ice cream
and browser simply line and through the out
like to welcome you won't decree is the
base of the century to day and joined by
two lines of cloud computing
industry baby king deer stag with
each other so he long voice is better
it could be one hell of right now that's
made a candy this
omf who have an abs cruise beautiful
bit I go ice cream and then my right we
go microsoft azure cover washable anti
have got sweet d wibi the divorce was
bertha van de bases off their origin en
the features that met's pro white paper
his depression day and comparing them
taught surprising make chine
options video and in since configuration
well injury is one the link
statements led state must be every hour s
lands in 2006 ida lewis is just on the
chest commonly used cloud computing
ceilings applause the words company
ooze gift at netflix abe libby
exclusive beers and sporty he gave
toe tv-visie.be lesson for this plateau
amsterdam and something the cloud functioning
computing' join the arctic fox for
piet file or the ink i'm a chat
software
nobody seems quite close to be in daknam
book I have us all to be white or wide
range or something so that's possible was complete
name want to be a flower in slack champion
networking storage migration and so much
more now let's see what is your heart
driver today
the showroom is lunch and the 1000 m and is
plastic me to a mosque types in the of
fortune 500 companies the best of the
best companies in the world youth
add only way to show if jewish
provide services
morgan agree yes the cloud service
provider in the living jogging sport i to
regional 3d and torment how alien plan to be
made of jewish provide more than hundred
services voltage on you reach on the
does the die again statement mean so
then leds have luka the cart and make it
status or not the union became so this
is the performance you had
stands for the market share or video lesson
when young and old the piaggio is removed
this is for that oil till as a loan
offer
amazon web services stitching wapping for
the fit on the market check closely
followed by jews to that patient and
old bastard in it to deep cents anyway
this track types and in the kids mad at
my party theorycrafting using the
dead us via number one picasso van
joseph x bwin centers scripture clay this
all to usals
show you the make the lido do you still have
manufacturer happy to be reminded you
e-type cent or the fortune 500 companies
crystal show does not cover land computing
the oil companies show me especially
lyrics left the remnants the door types and
that's a an abs everything your account to
the resembles the cloud service providers
google cloud platform
rackspace he bim software and salon nou
for an exor the comparison dream fixed
baby combining classic who biologist in the
closet and for very basic instance it is
the watcher machine or do what your cpu and
ethical question for did him now is so
such a box proximity zero point
shadowline take us dollars off and on
the c at least in the shop in the car show
proximedia soul panji my chicks us
dollars
next up with compair buddy and options
dim inch and the full etap lewis is the anti
propels it easy lido when it comes
to the cloud computing toemai looked at
four types and the market share my 20 man
I had lewis is our expected to be
used weiss it can be a to have new
white lace close to [ __ ] you for being
told
not to mention établi us is council ik
voltage is oil flow monastery or
words of this services to for fills the
shifting business alignment or on my
visions all kinds of discreet
your club video what the research
company but no gas oil system in order
with your hearts you see see the competition
is it just neck between angela and abs
solium edge of time before joining
crisis of the straw that only in market
share and juice parsi who becomes us this
more likely sides gringo is a camp
on my clothes from établit georgette
satisfy their business needs and just
not far behind établies windith comes
the services as well as right so so already
big juice constantly updated and influence
anti-fog users were spy the cloud
computing the climate
tablet can barry the blush and enjoy free
life left
etap lewis provide if i live i in die
promised services for free shape and you
just get hand own experience at de
platform for that number is the videos
offices for to the to cut services dat
a uhm is a free forever to the nobility
there the valet only find your own with
free cagri of wax bottom greenpeace
obesus fan jumpy amazon sns ask us cloud
will I become sector to the vale for your copy
or as approximately 20 services for your
family amazon s3
easy to elastica i sector
botex of services family metz on the
usage examples for each member of the
glass computer it sector
what you so if i just for you sing
services
have for countries we the father forio
macleane disapproval you of the usage and
shop provider feel and both with our for
my choice is that ends up in the category
of free for you and always give them a
bar trendy 5 plus all wifi service is
provided by show the thing close up
service functions containers all with up
to buy cheap and lots more and hesitated
safe video animals eat so dirty or something
this linux or windows swatch machine
blog storage and skin hydra base and
fuel if you ever have a provides users at
credit on access the us dollar the promotions
of the service is some portuguese
well so in June feature that so pure
white
users can use the credits to your place
in the service of the choice with the
entire man now let camp in which stunts
configuration to leave since then stadium
on your salvus is therefore hoping to their
flight is cubic flemish and sixteen
warsaw cpu the lodges the that your
office is a mare fabian every toe
go and level the ubisoft window and
sixteen turns red cpu and now for the
final roon the slightly contestant de
pension [ __ ] and they have to which the
missions for that sfax
who could do the rapid fire on fast way
and features in which i know bioguard ns
us better I give that a present if necessary
and videos i or lessons users have
bought it shines like war management
to the us part and yoko slightly deep de
service is this full of them ten cate
gui's drip tray pannas is different and in
just such as a service
next back on hybrid cloud with evolutions
god and as joris better ok under em us
tonight and forsyth from hybrid cloud
olio di af focusing words technology
language and jurgis sometime they are
hybrid cloud and its speech and
supporting the center ds on the
reception for the him we passed blues
further and if york score of course it's
better clean the cash register florists
integration the quote by the applications
wine a shoplog at tactus die
data centers blame and scalable
architecture for pricing becomes a
blush anne's year had a lemme
excuse for edom us because it provides
so competitive and political reading price
in fashion and in the molar at a show I
try many stars consent
experiment report to provide a few dat
we the plague xvideos
and there is also a selfie in west
hitman's
well let's just surprising die
call it something cloud computing' place
of it and then for his chance
choosing the right man is based in
timely when subscribers apply with
highlights when eduard in the baby special
and dust you leave in the daily value best
cloud computing' instead of willoughby
amazon web services
woman like deployed santing plank de
badge cloud computing instead of is or
whiskey book sheet platform do this en
reverence must have an undertone she is
do you panic the human being unclean with google
cloud platform grass cheaper instances
is i had to say but we are in the sun
one place within a few discuss so
boxing ring so at simon page and tidy
google cloud ceiling and women
portraying bso welcome to fight night
this is an ops was gpp
the winner already my videos to the basil
air origin and the videos that benefit
have depression b and can am i
do the business uprising jane
options de ding zwingli for free and
set up drip side to bottle let's
talk about eating meat before continued how
them by the date before and in the
cloud ladies place of this house
I turn businesses browns at pride en
services the took there on your friends my
skis the medical team champion
database stories migration networking en
so again in partner bacon the bar in the
vs it is see is also speed called libians
inside the make i lay sprawled in indiana
cold house place of me whose that rather
business where and keep in concord de
business joy or such an abyssus left from
porn and starts everything and refresh in the
late quarters is an indication of
motivated and terrace people are no de
to yes the haque boldly for
create applications with a significant
sank as the cloud computing make tha
also prefer this she would call it
moment a little more just about every issue
that your hair can be smart be delayed on
you sometimes after that was great but now come
the talk about jcp he hope you another
arty jury was lunch again recently taal
his lips and it's all that genting
business a significant life de suite
finds aliens i want to cloud your facts
computing services
I watch your neighborhood fold to scylla
cations website services as an intro
such as
the intuitive user I muscle capable that
zibro white white dashboard decided is vb
their all those aspects
chibi has just got in the market and it is
oil offering a mode to bloxam sister
to the numbers of the link reading to
the coffee for the seaview profit and sorry
they disturb you look your super white is a
big chipo to that our chain
mankiewicz and their money storage now becomes
your htc one act of chocolate just let you
this press wall in often that look and the
make cloud check the order or do
then his team so a rally of his
wife that one blisters love and i
opportunity the cloud computing'
amazon web services came that broke for
design class are the market share but
so random spacer verizon ready newspaper
neighborhood and chicks patient microsoft edge
japan die put voting pass and the google cloud
platform can be your neighborhood [ __ ] and
iams or nice because that neighborhood tribus it
for design patient of the market share is
quarter of an hour this with an abs you
thinking along with you anymore
how i know all the drawers fine but would i
tested views beard and a fox icon zo
buddies such a laugh of time I get
you have become read news aafje miss oil
who are on windows block know for 4
million on the rotation and ones plus mix
van phoebe lyndon is what will I become
could now i do the sign lamp time before
i king and get close yes yes yes how is
t well let kamp are viewing fourstar de
[ __ ] compare price for religious and
computers are so cool cpu are
energy wheel to costs proximate
light system us dollar well computer one
simple you might be in which you
can specify the word operating system
name or hair [ __ ] by idiots
stories I poop and piss and what you guys
of earn feather you really wanna do
let the greenhouse jelly bean winflash go
stand let's take the same champion in
stunts on then cpu this epidural i want
cost place it I prefer to do lobo
month vinci siepie and next to my
task vials that it twenty five
percent to lucas maximum and camp to us
talking about folding chair something costs it is
only two cents boogie boy lame [ __ ] ecb
moral stuani so eeh let's deadly
buddy an option now in hopes is the
cuyp market leader in the comes to cloud
computing do you remember the continuous
release party adaptation of the and at
market share gps at 1000 kees of this
would erase would like to prevent moment
it's a clear indication or do you keep it
members with at the stands decision makers and
it's the grill yes you see what you
builds needed at psi pi is tatty glowing
who havel from sixties everything is there
arrived in as i have a sigillo to it
lot more to come xo liam mother of time
and who we rush not so precise as
you too many companies of oil state
adopting choose ipsi cloud service
provider now just as many teams you can
for free we share bless you can access
journal
all over and and thighs with usage limit
the limits in pure and arie where the
many pieces for example with amazon easy
to juliet send and receive the la's man
coat owl hat other request
spectators is for the john brummen
iblis landa your hair a little less vulnerable
man now to haggle have to class you
just and the zipper with jeep i you get a
chance to go je kout rather than plan
the mire fire is a good size sepia
and son who in our chicken gianni dolos
credit the 's-pen by the 12 month
python all the cloud platform grass and in
issue behind the freeze dried agree you
would be just an issue miley also w2p de
lace now then sold to the or if i wish
for which you we're not an admirer
pilling account your you get to users
bolin stunts for free and 5 gb of cloud
storage and new set of bin so already with
free you wish me with my that machine
I do not stand by law the grtz never
stop hold your chin carp in
chairs we did blast the drawers
instant' assaf even of it introduction
blues and vote now had that arm de
moon with the place and people before you
may know to use spartan swiss
well that dat we situations where iona
trick is so nice persistence and know nobility
and interaction you may for the spar price
perfect importer of those fir brushes
target area you know but after that sister
raided chorus de drawers instance of
will be the google cloud is one sixty cpu
archive 175 typical digging site spoke
instances of g.us how we cloud or a
shot lift computing course sweet bee
in advance short and for torrent workload
work olive projects we instances something like this
instances sarah do we want atp percent of
pony monthly price hence the read shop
champion toe cost significant cream
en light établi lesbian can be nice
fitch fry google cloud blame is the not
more flexible and it comes to instance
from losing your sims at you just cpu and
ram condition of course you can even
create your own in sometimes a while so again
the carbohydrate tablet can be slowly
auditing therefore works and who is the pee with
our porto marie curie collecting
billard i girl human of the murders
points nutrition simple geebee jibi is
albus lead better I as dhcp hour
telemetry tool with ships rise
services and dedication beautiful on typical
point is i can see stack times
support times the playsuit went wrong
edgar so the have josm x-files on the
webcare members kept jumping out of the best
before comic you are the customer's
dna are both we jibi banking is a
workshop flat hose in a user always
exercise so was original idea sheet
we flowers
cheesy bras for medical report for the
when anne cloud services we just
fine-tuning to know like you minutes
stands a kind of our this and things give
the slaughter africa shows of cattle and
mind evolution of those appliques is how
candide applied is not the card lessons
term mind
my chances your profile in a blister
in fact none of them reboot book us one
in the chips the pain remained mine
noble cold let your buddy chat and
jabbeke location now it's time for the
big fish and so how they can be
yes how is a point i be the city of
anyone who expresses their lesson the go for
choosing the right cloud communion
platform this is all the more than the
business on my user
but the unethical grime and
rather merge orange i be a view of the
world's largest cloud service providers
despair this de from from each other
let's find out hey guys and women and
ipad apps and stuff amazon web services
on german you in highbury presentation
microsoft azure and i'm sure thee and
shares percent in google cloud
platform so welcome to this video and i
did you sisters his show is a ski
siepie coffee mug market share amazon web
services we left appropriate until now
or the worldwide public cloud jack and
jones on the sixteen patient of the long
night market share angie beyoncé online
patient on the world market share with
sticks to the service providers in die
part is called the bluff project services de
the neighbor users to create and deploy
obligations how we use the cloud those services
doctors zaboo fanned internet no
blush pink that war the last post land
and the youth do when I put on a show
lunch and the 1000 and is a computing
platform that offers a wide range of
services to big nine eight end blue
applications under just what using tools
and frameworks wage symbiotics chinese
gp's appliqués a tab my teeth
integration services for each end users
in addition to cloud management at auto
or service is what i did machine charge
to that booty now let's talk about on
willoughby that sun she slept
location within the death in the region
from which public cloud services
original and apple the suit I appreciate
the usa that her sixty nine willoughby's
in query tool job meet the regions is
a lurking regions in the united states
would america europe and asia pacific
those pink objects skin plywood
edition of the future
edgar and wheels begin one for the
conscious hazel of the four reasons why
white group in the nitrogen exactly
the same beovision is her modern one
dogs that want bag and kill jibi they
belinda van der plas countries across
the world as of today gp's percent in
sixty one sons late 20th jeans with sacca
and jurick offer new lia ribbon regions
well let's talk about pricing die
services of the pr ziggo approach jp
oil for the in dude sauce is unique to
the lamb euston the devil planning
hose clamp pliers trucks complex licensing
well on screen you can see the pricing for
each of these cloud service providers
with respect to pay the synthesis leak
general purpose champion on the most
mammy at your most and jpu well with sticks
what the computer software from it who
your workshop service for the reason blaze
who its easy to this is a website with
which eliminates the need to in west en
hardware so your friend lab and the
bloom applications in a solid men
ran rights watch and machines in which
you can run your applications just watch
is a machine when the ciphertext or
computing resources at your office als
yogis should have flexibility by deploy
and manage and what you in my room en
unless the social network gp's wim is like this
and labels used to build this blog ant-man
and george and machines to run workflow
john the cloud well go baguette pricing
of use of the services edu plus easy to
is free to try this package as part of
their debut video
that last 2 months and to write some
free as per month or bot linux en
windows switcher machines and john green
machine service is a park in the field
whether there is juice for the batavus the ios
paul maria the use and get access to
windows sound lina swatch machine gps
who is him like this is a partner for video
dat in closed my grow in family tree on for
up to 12 months now let's the bart spot
of people suicide pass oriental for a
or us elastic beanstalk is a
easy-to-use service for blogging and
skilling web applications and services
him run jaguar that net node.js
brighton and much more interviews from
my dating to fit that provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and
application it easy the boss
backbone you class is what selection
technical with the workshop machine is
independent of the hardware costs
hence the user can write application
cold but what up a guideline hardware
google app engine is a cloud computing
platform is a service which is used by
tumblr already post hosting and billing apps
in google data centers that a page
requires the apps to be read in english
piping and cool detail in google big
table and use google query language for
this next let's talk word watcher
primatch hr services edoms bride flight
sim diploid June 17th and
applikation the website took a living
securities monty plan and minimum number of
configurations in simple live via match
is a nice compliment image for
microsoft azure roger machine in it
cesium and you gigi some solutions in the
modules minutes but fortunately i jeep
ides normal for one is now 11 is
next up who might be computing
services serious mass countries it is
both les compute service that let you
honey' agreed thanks for sharing and
but the spectators who see oil peak for
the computer use it is used to execute
mark in court and skills automatically
belt enterprise john functions is
same lesson computer service that lets
you run identical or modified x positive
or is in arnhem central station this
allows users to black edition using some
simple functions with the programming
language of their choice this pilot
functions make it easy for double a
poster of a ski resort in the cloud en
bill image-3 wish will come
topoccasions it is highly a lot
and then follow rent now let's talk bad
story services of there at each of the
service providers probably wondering who's on it
jack storage the whisper white s3 this is
an object to reach the provider
industry standard scalability did
willoughby and of it is extremely
durable and can be used for malfunction is
sometimes the king of information africa
for a new and about the internet blog
disorder enjoy feature that lets
gladstone fear archer detail in
microsoft cloud platform hello with
storejet or something or escape the threshing
detail in the form of tias depending on
how often the ice beam access google
cloud storage is an online store it
web service for malfunction unboxing petalon
google cloud platform infrastructure and
like to google drive google cloud
storage is you need the counter for
enterprises in our sometimes on jack stada
frame two pockets
amazon proline pbf
difficult blog tough it provides high
performance blog storage and is used
alone with icidu instances for workloads
third transaction gets intense and
journalist is a lotion heart is your child
singles party nice disc in one
amphibious sober with boxing list that is
my is this love the used to create
up-load and a thousand beyond is in one
singlet subscription boy system storage
the detail storage device that doesn't even
dating off the power to the wiser shot of
google bass player in this case dual en
high-performance blocks to reach for gpp
system disk bright storage which can be
a touch to instances running in idle
google computers and argu within that are
jo next up we have start recovery
services in the blue sprites and cloud
based upon the service the in shows that
your ideal to structure and they are
covered by minimizing the mountain down
time that could be quick site your comedy
have sensor business community by keeping
business apps and botless running thing
cars I read recovery at every
string to all those less application
process of law the butcher machine
between these on fortunately sibley
haasnoot disaster recovery service
maxlead sticks barbie barbie choices
for span for us via abs sorry limousine
service this is web service always
cost effective
to artemis at least chantal basically
it's advice to setup oppression and
skilling or losing my tip is
microsoft azure sql database is the
software as a service platform 13 close
button intentions deadlines separate us
to adapts to maximize performance de
guideline indd protection with all sorry
sixth migration of fast glass over
databases with ancient chinese applications
cloud sql is a foil moon in bull
thabiso is how so easy to set up my
team and that minister relation postgresql
mysql end sql server database is in the
cloud grungy siepie cloud ask you will
provide a day that is infrastructure for
applications running anywhere next rehab
noise your database services ede extinguishing crew
eyeliner but baby it's a man is
expensive and confessed beast that pro white
security make-up and the store and
in-memory box for applications this is
my wages for the slowly agency and
scalable shapes like japanese had to baby is
microsoft globally the student maitimo
database or is this not the riesebos yet
once i don't club the lisabo snow sql
creates this for you it and sea and
scalable applications jibi cloud details
target is a mysql database oh fish or it
by google om de jeep at higher education
and skills automatique lead to your
education hit with cloud your bag
review to party that can easily die
actions for an idea prime and target nou
with sticks become key cloud boat for
each of the service provided for us in
networking in short a delirium because of a
blood test 3 ne de bus cloud for for
management wifi the flashy notepad no
the bus cloud of mission modern ben
again the extinguisher is short and everyone
blitz corput for security via pm and
key management service for microsoft
azure networking pump in the baby could
children who have neck and expresso for
management tools we already have shaer
advisor and neck workshop for the late
take my test for management with me
take care with shell and necklace watch
the bar retired studio light and
enjoy leaf studio for security measures
also efficient and kind
so jazzy baby had the following tools
for networking and content delivery who
gave claus chili and and claudianus for
management who hastag rival and jibi
monitoring for the leaf min 3 red cloud
bill at the end cloud is the king and fine
rather security who her google cloud
time and google end of cloud sync' advice
canal barely stick with the camp site
using these cloud providers for the bios
via on netflix june lip gloss nassar
nokia and the loopy exams an idea how
this is how i am see and bm family amadeus
microsoft azure look like this if your
screens the companies such use case epa
spotify patches baby snapchat hotel
paypal and stripe white century fox with
sticks body the wonder use of the
services amazon prime is enterprise
family services you can leverage and mine
sons 15 years of experience the living
lounge times global infrastructure and is
still can't be used to home and i made
it infrastructure management skills and
capabilities secondarily it provides gain
en exercises ibis is designed to allow
application providers eyes with en
windows to quickly and securely coach
applications with an excisting
application or news sbs application
speed agility
ditto is project shakti procession agree
with the minutes oil is not the select
what hurts you and you can do exactly you
kun axxes each of these applications in
the time don't do it now and finally it
security level amazon enables you to
innovate and skill your application
security warm this secures and had a
kind of got you bomboogie the project
security and the type cost and overmaas a
beautiful human model gigabyte model straps
whether your microsoft azure or is better the
map and operations and also provides
trump security bv georgian strong
focus on security
power supply that security mode' on
deck 6
homeless step light and close your eyes
to provide a cost-effective solution de
cloud in wares mental as business is
gateway to custom applications in
than an apps in the cloud with Zeeland
night i messed up to cost and set up and
friendly lets look at the advantages of
three jailer google bills in minus it
label increment will you oil pepper de
computer you see also provide is cancer
price is for long running workload
food offer use to be in for a man
can get a discount
jibi our core white light migration of
fortune machine live migration is the
process of moving and running bm from one
physical so much and after we tahm
kench shopping in tables blood i to
the users this is another catchy one
friend shadow from google cloud can join
do all the cloud providers jcb pro white
automatic' steal the cello politically
site allows an escape to as mini sibiu
assenede google cloud storage is
designed for nineteen and tuna we are
durability
it creates rebecca and store voice in one
new she can single location let's talk
about the disadvantages of each of the
songs for drella bios this limitation of
the sea to summit in the wall sprites
limitations on the sources that way the
fun beach intrigue there may be a limited
number of instances that can be cries
we have uc in the quest for the slim is
to be increased secondly the have
technical support via the blue star
you for i made it support and i one on
for any of these packages del lido beach
cost grandin endless my mouth business
which cosmo the hands dennis and and de
price that costs more than 15,000 dollars
i hate would network connectivity and
should i do as general issue with many
more the cloud place than with him you must
the office every protection and torn hoe
we had to the september issue and can
be dealing about time talking about some
of the the semantic of microsoft one
kind of core business be the friend
[ __ ] offline and in usa modification
my blog of the cloud bass ecosystem is
mode is efficient and boring and john
management console is fast red i do
what about it is louis was born in a bit
and often requires by mini click to
watch i simply just a sharp apis int en
this for buck in that malfunction
detail located on a time is a cell
fixed the cloud just the great feature but
this mustache videos for the before doing at
with him exactly through them as in the demo
details and go let's new look into the
time on the job jibi in a bowl of soup
cloud providers so already booty is ready
minimal pair in the case of gibi
descried coarsely it's an unwise to
do lobo man for the most basic so with
similar daily dead us sci-fi bras en
complex crying stima our white mustache
gary budget family inside shoot
downloading the dat from google cloud
storage
well just in a certification
constellations big shot glass and edgar
and how you can become a cloud engineer
and in a glass solutions architect
yes ok bye paul that step x want us
even though that was my plate in edam us en
and show intro passions where I am now
an animal the blush the election website
pisslink baby in the description and well
who a hundred short time so much the bus
by election as you can see here
the reptiles have them to give you the bus
is election is the foundational and
the social and professional and
certification to the foundation live
kind of election only require you to
have basic understanding of how deer de
bus cloudbox the one blew out that
suspicious practicality is optional die
grab this pad of lubbe and
operations at in so my idea of ​​the
specially that would make the election bad
the headlines networking just take this
so would elections
well that associates heavily the
election armageddon certification for
detecting the room nou on professional
education is the sharks sleepless
election that you can her for the
technical or will you had the solutions
aqueduct for that architect path and the de
watts engine and certification connected
just share them per and operations path
here these are the jobs that are so de
election are suitable for you see you
sinia den lorde blizz bry second kind
elections for a broadcaster john gross
always access my studio solution
architect lämmle so you need to make the
right choice things that conservation die
idiom your interest and xp de slot
natural knowing by now then something happens
of the third i prefer to be that thing
so frosty stepping at the honor de
blossom the five cloud horse between le
then who is all files down the bliss
one we learn to start small
so its fixation validates the view
how well you know the de bliss cloud ze
so this is the basic understanding
well this is definitely for the daimler
button die operations pan ipods and this
is a co-leader to start your is it
from the silent backdrop to all that god
it's something you can do along well beautiful
boggie then need in which you deck my
channel inch or had plumbs clear
an architect you to discussion just like
hard so great place to start for
new one can, well that architect
louis certifications thus there of your fire
in all to do becoming with solutions
architect for the solution design
be engineer like ananias max be
ding applications as system when the
medlar no fuss via the honor the buses that
often solutions uptick social education
well the are ficus us for you how views
or how much you charge the battery opaque blue
edition probing bus platform now it is
recommended that you have at least one
years of experience working with de
stuburt systems on did on the speech
of it's a game something like a
required eduardus stand learned blood
services and baby recommend and so is
based on the garments june do die
have the you architecture in speech
cushions to June the first joined blue
skies and how you could really use the
next up you that whole blizzard fact
solution business think professional at be
election now new not get the
certification arles sur then note the
blood vessel solutions architect at zo
more serious ficus will show off your
technical skills and experience in
designing the sibilla positions on the je
so saves them in terms of you to have two
years of experience what in the cloud
architecture' when the west end is em
in our and guys you to be able to leave
a like to clients and then make
battery cover recommendation yo they don't
provide guidance and the most practical is
and also that you are mattresses number
or you find late for the dead bat
evans would the election itself in your fire
dustin and becoming and will walk on
than those in the extinguisher divided and walk
if oh [ __ ] certification is the test how
will i know how the devil on and my
servant watched when the plus black
because of that they have you
poverty and then I speed and to be and
my dinner is usually formwork
click any software clear roll it is
necessary that you know in became least
one hi leather programming language i
would it be so neccesary that you meet existing
coridup your services users and basic
architecture best practices june the baby
the are clear and those ply cloud based
solutions only the blizz beard of aan
june and the standing hall monkeys christmas
candy tree the hydra mix human in the
looping and maintaining monkeys choose
another again the bus oasis seemed on
my sns almost zero db sqs and so on
for that earlier extinguisher the friday babs
if your professional website is still
in the so would elections is I saw
you the cms confused now bang the the
operations or they offered the with the cm 20
year I dessert buttocks die to create a
great and me not beechwood a monkey
occasions when the bliss place of now
it is necessary because it is my baby
hd review site of the runners oh [ __ ]
certification from one blizzard
varikse sapsite do you miss the certification
with by fashionable or hands-on experience
in burgess one units plus in my me
confused you to be have clear
corner case mannheim language i need to
be able to automate and desta
progressions where you scripting and
programming and the countries are like you
recommended clear brassers who
oppression certification savio simone de
comic sap site my study systems out
my [ __ ] that was all in the app
store were you the propagation snap what
can systems be blended into an old one?
deliberately bid the one put out the fights
and sapsite machines are oh [ __ ]
election test your knowledge in the
prime and management and operations on
the in the plus platform now you need to
have a more your hands on experience in
ede bliss based applications should be
able to identify and guidelines game de
final solution to be operated on the
most unique multiple providers for the
so spoke if second-line they want
for projects quickly that the specialization
kitchens a few antlers was ten appetite and
be showcase their expertise at the
tank empty is the earlier with all the
fight back did so the vacation showcases
euro political are and implement
to get you together so that I am a shepherd and we you
of me did large amount of complex
johan our guideline completed the
foundation for associates letters and de
election big bore that can damndest
in-ear the middle my five years of
hands-on experience and that he afterwards x
plus some extra have the honor of the extinguisher
divide watching what are those chests
so where are you this year
can be and implemented plus
illusions as well as other high bright
so the network architect is the ship
if there is in terms of youtube complete the
foundation arm so more serious the
election so far have minimal
fires of hands on experience
architecting and implementing just what
solutions and loss lydia honor the flash
idevice security certification I have
shock is years bus that circulated the
bisback from you the guide to heaven
associates there cold makes is no less off
the election and minimal vso video
securit x-files and pretend her
son I spying them inspection I do is
which was loose yes because there between those
linen are mission so for me samurai
wonder do that solutions architect
education to first he doesn't belong
rich and click under the cancellation and the
process can that news on rock and click
Download
but i also do anakins judik sanusi
here from your look up in actions to the
detail line the number of questions of
milly bole the cost of an exam
nation the cost is not the stadiums
horn toilet steps to loss my
bag and I would win that election with the
members moby dick well this would be the
vacationing together closet of the us
dollars and the practical exam costs and
that was everything still here item show you the
examination or download december become
I downloaded that sum of money and so you
that's x m line dance you about become u
don't plan and get a six pack this from
grd you have to do the final solution based
on the garments and provide guidance in
the implementation is shed recommended
that i 0 borgo di in the exactly is what
when is or hands-on experience we
distribution strain when the burj dubai
and design define technical requirements
and so is the rest is because
blindly and there and most
importantly this part your the main can in
so man and the know now who her
find a means for mood is by de
his switch in architecture' with you
hear your focus and two ditch I the
two please your skin liked my battery
so who is the specific therapy kissing
snarkitecture guests at the most
architecture' are five offerings of
operation ax link catcher then you look
on see here you select what would the
election and then this unique you can
do the meaning of a job that will be the would
the election that compress learner and
download them dry and let's see that
you not now hi guys and brewer from simply
long and occasionally debut the talking about age
more assertive kitchens not before i go you
little bit of the day led wired talk
about becoming saki is and de
justification
study as yo certifications oxley together
nations third tried at microsoft
choose help you validate pickaxe your
fear of the conception of jacques en
although you can what must be those
basically basic or under that your kid
show off the social play win
barton by find comes to herring on
promotion here already vis limo likely be
selected a few are certified
professional nou diseducation
scarborough wide range of the commons en
those certificates us how we do
it and specified room for example has a
deficiency that's called beep I can already
solutions architect at en als yoram en
shake aramis yard and walk now is
you can also veneer it men thing is to
why you be taking up and the jacket off the
election no review murder like you
desk white spa flood that day on a
division agency knew he was creating
intel and applications as your head mode
hands would be star span also wide
range of domains the auto has satisfy
great number of requirement kills die
fitting or the fortune in which it
companies use microsoft azure for the
cloud computing' requirements not to
mention the sap nations dead us
microsoft product and oxley or again and and
the price agreement the kipsang discounts
on a few hours and finally if you
provide solutions across forty-two
regions confused it's more than i je
the cloud service provider thousands
market right now now let's talk about
as jacket from the election as he looked
not that you become or become microsoft
popular certifications set the mood so
fine tree to simplify two three and six
hours offline two fine art microsoft is
changing the template what certifications
microsoft news vacations would be a de
mic de in the region for all in job
articles red for december as you
admin street associates sjm walking
associates as yo solutions architect
and die as your day walks engineer expert
it's a bit of microsoft interviews in
de i their confidence that took place
on September planning for the microsoft
introduced youthification city full and de
in its category well the become and so
your from measured associates june de
hate that is and won 107 kitchen wat die
microsoft edge o' infrastructure and
deployment and the first one was a hot one
microsoft at your integration and
securing the become and that you're dead
do you walk that is it access
droplets that microsoft like you
tablet core solutions education and easy
to zero one of the microsoft edge yard
and walk because solutions are preferable
fine let become solutions architect
you that is the trigon this that me
interesting that your architect
technologies and that's a trees there
just on the microsoft azure architects
are those two roles in cues
concepts my uniform and the i to could
window spot after those oh sorry vacations
defy 3 the facts i invite you for
libridis champion of the 3rd of piece
december total are a team they become
do they have the people how often you
it that's why microsoft lync use the
ears and one zero to to will toe
entries eurotour transition second
vacations now rebuilt deed in one
air mattress let's go into all of the
news would vacations in that part they
well let's talk about i would put more
my hands or the microsoft azure infra
structure and deployment would traffic
they will basically packing slip of to win
it comes to becoming and seo from my
stripper discourse of the insects find
us dollars barely keep the silent
forest pictures I are together the dome one
piece not the limiter for and there mash them
with tidbits she was June 12 quite you can
but not at your subscriptions in the
cream puffs in the wash
managing subscriptions and giving a lecture
socials on a used and how they consume
and managing a kill like groups chili
him implementing and managing storage
unit and eyes you can create en
configure accounts keep your kin import
and export earlier by show confit dat
your eyes and keep your chin implemented you
baking danny heb deploying and managing
what you machines you that kinda you can
creates a configuration of machines for
windows of linux unique know-how in
arnhem i the flower and the watcher machine
unique quite you can manage and judge
machines and manage what you might
backups then you need to know how you
can conflict and manage what you
networks unique that have created
connect you deep i win watcher
networks keep you able to implement
something you take networking confido
extinguish user groups family unique
know-how you know my a site then this
unique be able to manage your art to
dark chris and juni the know-how you kin
implement and management ai thinks is the
neck stepping becoming and as you guess
my strip is to do that is it afraid
will be hot what those menkes uncas yes
integration and security certification de
ez banjo man on the microsoft azure
integration and secure the certification
rohs a target embodied in their earnings
becoming and if you scare me
the certification comment section of us
dollars well then we look at some of
the important topics that you need to
know what this is a mission to be so late
we also it should potions that you
need the west wit we from balance exam
litter of steps january waiting and
performing cell migration to measure
den we have implementing and managing
a politician and sauces version lives can
fingering we are therefore computing managing
absolute plans and managing absolutes
danny him implementing exhaust swatch
just walking dead their lives implementing
application load balancing implementing
it your load balancer morning and
manager networking in the clothes that
answer me put what we who is your
network and so long and family security
think who is unique who have the
implementer but often percentages
kitchen perjury and red beast control
system implementation has hit young at
place and plus identity management them off
the jordan with is it man harding
mongrel one you become and microsoft
certified sja I associate my fart
with word they have the beep how be
who then that implementing Microsoft young
infrastructure solutions a description
of the seven seas of rhye 3 3 is for
the people that might would he is the is
in banjul also on the microsoft azure
from my keys from the ficus in
transition
after this examination that god give me my us
download contains concept by beauté
are one hungry and committed to the norm and
this xm is to be your app for people who
be di campli this so we have
will fact three would that party now if
you have completed the seventh eurovite
city ​​he suggest you this transaction
would the elections bring that clique or
this would be this you can now at microsoft
with the flameproof march 2000 10 well let's
have look at how you can be calm and
microsoft certified as your download
associates to do so June de campi
purpose would vacations be the first access
the bottom aixam edgar double paco
solutions and fashion and the first toe
and than one from microsoft radio
dab on the brand solutions at wrong
you just told me succeed the first access
there is this certificate shanice part one
or two in one comes to be coming and not
your tablet associate i had started drumming
real from us dollars well so exam
nation is in betta vis
beach least and seems to be
nations where you get your results so nice
or instagram issue so i'll draw you
lies one or two weeks the for your kinget
joris from the questions as to be what then
and in shifts pan this absolute titian
access the people can take the me there
with the moment hardly keep it too
should potions that yoni the perfo
for so I save minutes
June be able to select in the prop again
cloud technology solution based on air
a little person is my warm computer
loopen integration order failure
solution nex june the bbq damn it up for
cloud storage you have to wash the loop
solutions that in my stories cable
aspires to this creates media business
and so much more june the bie have the
create place of people swimming solutions
with you never creating web applications
mobile applications services would
once functions and so much more
and family juni de bie infringement plus me
your cloud solutions don't give you the
implement and kitchen access control and
secure just like a loser
well microsoft recommence that your hair we
choose year whether I have smelts walking with
microsoft your creating monkey pillows with
if you have tools and technology while at
the same time gave me worries than the
standing especially the fish juice software
who wish to
well that would work the next up becoming
and microsoft if your developer is not too
close the first one his cheek on the
microsoft azure the cast i am
solution certification the literal that
that's me domination is all white advice
and the mother of the was an experiment
and such an oh god and sixes of us dollars
well let's have look it will have to
potions that you don't prepare for this
is a mission you need to know how you
can they platform if you never too
at least clear for auto scaling
also have long running costs
is you want the customer auction and so much
more
unique another week and implemented
integration solutions I manage in eps
they napier management configure message
with integration architecture
tablet and application message mode and
summers more and finely unique know-how je
kindle app with joost cook not the
services bar and out those solutions in
libya de creates in the great but creates
and implement those solutions and king
technique used as yoko minute or services
and monkeys gave a kiss expensive then that's what you have to do
you can meet microsoft certified if
jorna wil now associates let's talk
about is there when she turns red that's the
tooth chinese la mission for anyone who
is then seven will guide to two of them
looping microsoft at your solution
certification now just like the
transition would vacation discos night
to us dollars and I this in the betta
fish
well this is accessible for only people
were then the seventh eurovite wudu
anne-sophie bill only for a limited bfm
this would be discontinued from the
doorposts are much to do and that this
has influence concept style in boot
bet two hundred and easy to undermine
concept corpse damping for cloud storage
creates a platform is a service
solutions
secure and cloud solutions attenuation for
a geocache marder implementing cloud
integration solutions that's why I have a
machine learning and now you're the
solutions well off that here then we this
your child become and microsoft certified
if jordan want so see let's
feyenoord for you can become van
Microsoft certified as your solution
architect export for so unita due to
would vacations that is a two hands
and the is it three hundred and won well
let's have looqin is a 200 it's that
microsoft is your architect technology
ate you wrong that the first three go
doing is quiet in the better face and car
shame their sixty four dollars this is
but one of two before becoming microsoft
certified as yo solutions architect
expert well let's talk about together the
topics that you need to buy for this i
together nation unique rather you can apply
and cargill infrastructure which en was
indication there association consumption
clothing and configurator this is your chance
clothes and could fingering witcher
machines for windows and linux or the
measurement that tuck with a watcher
machines and some more than you need
logo you to implement workload and
security looks like my clothes sylvestris
show could philosophy lesson computing
implementing application load balancing
managing your base sister office
implementing but that factor
authentication and so hot danny june de
architect cloud technology solutions
unique be able to select a problem
computer lesions in the great solution
storage solutions you have the
create and the blog occasions like for
example tering web applications using
pas create and operational service de
by ourselves is factory
design web applications that line
containers and so warm you didn't de
implementations incipio they do and
finely you don't by clear for the
blow which means you need and oil
children's lamp longer a cupboard conficker
message base integration
clear for auto scaling implement
distributor transactions and as long as
is a discussion that require you to be
having export levels kisses in the groin
if your heart my discretion as jordan
on my judgment ups yo johny graphics
peter's with the way the step scenario
operations looks like networking watch live
nation security and stuff
this is because the jewish lotion
business take place within budget becomes the
fool stakeholders can become the
garments in the scalable secure and the
light solutions are old next up is too
do that is the reservoir what the
microsoft azure architects are they
party let's have looked at
he seemed all who would have vacations
discuss go their chicest fight everything and
is it in this plays is between the final
step into becoming and the drivers and
business thinks export well let's have look
it's a must topics that you guys de
prepare for this would be the election
facili you need to know how you kinda de
mind workflow de grimes you know how to
gather information undergarments the op
the mizen consumption fledgeby another the
its e-marketing and marching strategy
June the the are mainly think those in
security explained are actually the
team management to be authentication and
authorization and the marketing strategy for
a think of security the unique
know-how you can be and those there
took place solution minutes designer
data management sarge i did the
protection started the document detail
whistled and so you are now the design and
business continuity strategy fries on
points design sign to cover i started to
ensure that is do you want bluetea
designer disaster recovery sarge and door
the are and who the archiving you start
techniques to be for the happy with it
vision other is the joy in every design
human beings migrations and design and epa
integration started and finally you need
an accident in his historical [ __ ]
compute star jean networking star gee
people horn behind you then with all so
you be calm and microsoft certified agile
solutions architect export they become what
those people became that December
or 535 what that architect in microsoft
edge as solutions would traffic that
fact that is it ri will be access
that the ez riso is the transition
certification which has now us dollars
it's access and replacement for anyone
who then the south eurovite 3 vai
certification well this is a gene in it
better face but free last oil de mars
tiny house to house and finished my 10th
certification you can keep calm and
measures solutions architect export nou
so opportunities dust topics include in it
boat is a 200 and 300 and won concept
does this look like my inbox your requirements
designing ahead thinks a security
designing and business continuity
started to implement which shed and
security
implementing authentic in securing
did and the looping for the cloud well
some light mention this video to the
become muslim as yo certifications nou
there arola would be the traffic and bacon now
still hack them because i be focusing on
the more important role basics a mission
therapy interviews racing club the cloud
excel is a taste it is expected to grow
sem a team of three presses in the span
or does hare and a rabbit pi which
means less to be a great deal in
who do five planet trillion dollars
walking access in a 6000000000000
dollars in total are my ten and pretend
the house a small which is expected at
nike percent of all nations at war
for be using klout even is not mention
seminar happy she is our lands where she
just using cloud computing sauces and
his e-book their employees to
experiment and lots more with technology
slack machine learning and artificial
intelligence scale war 2 be going to the
fast lane baby talking bart how is a
cloud computing engineer the steps you
need to take the combs cloud computing
and snow and the cloud computing engineer
pure is she stuck wondering how is i cloud
computing engineer now a cloud
computing engineer is an ai die
professional codex care of all the
technical aspects of cloud computing
try design planning maintenance and
support now cloud computing engineer
can take up a number of different
career path this could be deed over
cloud the cubs security engineer
full-stack the want basic setup with a
straight a solution case i think cloud
architect and so much more and level too
doing it together major cloud computing
group fausto fiap solutions architect at
the is already in the widgetts are sponges
blood for analyzing the technical
environment in which there could produce
their solutions
the commercials and the specifications secondly
i dr guide to select in the prophet
technology that satisfies site requires
the need to estimate and one is the usage
and the operational costs of the
solutions february and things to support
project management as well it solution
development next week epse sap site my
shooters third warm in the blog managing
and upgrading highly skilled and for
those and sisters who are not the select in
the prophet will is based on computer
security of the dark warm and danny to
estimate and manage how do you set up
risks and those not able to migrate
another girl weak [ __ ] through the prop
again cloud computing platform so beautiful
bid it's roasting site in the grime and
that then the opinion could hardly parade
did not lure the step you thick the comb
and cloud computing' engineer your app
is the game proficiency in cloud
computing' platform that is the fixed step
to become proficient in preferably
walking seeing little cloud computing
platforms bday the price as your article
can your platform have disadvantages
scuse number there so you can fine
on the internet it could be
youtube videos articles we will
physical claesson are so much more nou
dislike that house looking these are the
five on microsoft azure in the bios
the google cloud platform for that
blush have number of dull and
certifications which can be divided u de
three category is you need the
foundational budget is the basics that
associates level old vacations de
professional and certifications and the
special design kitchen similarly with
microsoft so yes yes certifications de
new look to be calm and as you
tablet associates and asia poor creature
[ __ ] and if your architect professional
and the was in june now moscow
computer platform
have free time you can draw
wonders of the sprite a song and free
services for peter of time some of which
a free forever to you can use this
platform to your advantage and do it with
spoke like a gun now if you would
like more about cloud computing group to
check out simply pay youtube channel
den your competitors that playlist section
turns it and ran in fine comprehensive
videos on a number of different cloud
computing ceiling établi s and microsoft
azure aerator blister dory video stop
boardwalk i bag lee is an abs body
paint bk mead remained solutions architect
amazon easy to astley's media de
services and sew much more piazza di
gregorio
angers we stepped but what i pocket lee is
a shot the sheriff occasions provider
tube years together the sauce is seems machine
learning when you hit dark gray and
so much more and now the step to be
experienced in a coffin afraid of the